you never know who's watching who you're
going to or who you can impact
it becomes you're not showing up for me
i'm showing up for the other people
do the work today do everything you can
allow the team to take care of you and
then let's face tomorrow when tomorrow
comes
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the podcast
my name is rich roll and as some of you
guys know
among other things i am an endurance
athlete known for doing some crazy stuff
like double iron distance triathlons and
that time i did five iron distance
triathlons on five hawaiian islands in
under a week
well james lawrence aka the iron cowboy
makes all of that just sound i don't
know cute
this guy recently completed what i think
is one of if not the
most astonishing achievements in the
history of voluntary human endurance by
completing
consecutive
iron distance triathlons in 101 days in
other words for context every day
without missing a single day for 101
days in a row this guy climbed out of
bed swam 2.4 miles rode his bike 112
miles and then completed a marathon 26.2
miles on foot now
as somebody who has a bit of experience
with this type of thing even i have a
hard time comprehending it even though i
twice traveled to his neck of the woods
in linden utah
both for day 91 and day 100 to really
just get a glimpse of it for myself
well as you might have guessed he's here
today he's joined by his amazing wife
his better half and team captain sonny
joe
to help all of us make sense of this
crazy affair
in addition to just breaking down the
enormity of this feat
this i think is a really powerful
conversation that just might forever
change your perspective on human
potential it's also a master class on
mental toughness where it comes from
how to develop it
and the power we all possess to endure
the unimaginable as well as
the critical role that teamwork
community building and service play in
accomplishing audacious goals
as well as how
presence and mindfulness really hold the
key
to achieving the impossible
so without further ado
please hit that subscribe button kindly
tag that notification bell
and
let's do
the thing
um good to see you guys thanks for doing
this yeah buddy
last time i saw you you were in a
different state i would have been
i'm not gonna say i remember a little
bit better now yeah thanks um how is i
guess the first thing is you know how
are you doing like how are you
recovering how's the body doing how's
the mental state i know it's been a bit
of a yeah it's been a journey for sure
yeah uh
very different than coming off the 50 um
coming off the 100 i mean this is what
they warned me about coming off the 50
was hey there's going to be a letdown
there's going to be some depression
there's going to be some
whatever and coming off the 50 it was
just like this whirlwind right into what
was next and this one you know were more
established and
there i was already doing what i
was going to be doing coming out of the
hundred and so
and
you take a seven week adventure and turn
it into a 14 week adventure which is a
quarter quarter of a year
um that impact on the mind and the body
is significant yeah and i had
no idea
the level of which my world was going to
get rocked um we told him he didn't
listen yeah well you told him after the
50 and it didn't happen right so he got
all
cocky about it i did yeah i did i was
like i really did well it's funny and
i've said this before but had someone
asked me on
day 98 could i do 200 i think i think
somebody asked me that on on the therapy
table didn't they one night like close
to the end could you could you do
another hundred yeah and i was like
immediate oh absolutely 100 let's keep
going you were just in the groove but
then day 102 i was like how the hell did
we how did we get to this point i got
how did we even do that and so
it was very apparent and very amazing to
me the power that the mind
has and what it was protecting me from
and then
but the team could see it from the
outside looking in right because i i was
on
when we do these things we're on very
different journeys same storyline
different journeys right same time frame
different journeys
and so
and you don't go from like oh day 60 to
61 you go from things are normal to
i'm in a protective state you slowly
slip into
that and you don't realize you're you're
transitioning right like your brain is
compartmentalizing everything yeah and
just trying to keep you alive so yeah
blinders have you just focused on the
task at hand and everything else is
obliterated and my my team that
intimately knows me
meaning my wife you know she could see
a slow change but then she knows okay
this is not normal to what was there a
moment
where it tipped and you're like we're in
a danger zone situation here were you
ever
no concerned i've been beyond normal
i've been married to james way too long
for that
i disregard any morning since i think
the thing that was most
challenging was
[Music]
the mood swings so on the 50 he was
completely non-coherent there was no one
home and it was like we were guiding
this zombie through this journey where
this time around he had a little bit of
his mind
but thought he had more of his mind than
he did
and so there were some issues with him
trying to make executive decisions or
doing things that he had no business
doing
thinking his mind was right but then the
moods were all over the place and so
for me
i mean we've been married 20 years i
know exactly what type of person he is
how he behaves under certain
circumstances and what not so to see
these different moods and these
different personalities come out i was
like wow he is in a really bad place
because we've been married 20 years and
i've never seen this person
and so i
had to check myself and make sure that i
didn't internalize any of that and just
say
i got to get him through this and to
know there were things i wanted to say
in the moment that i had to check myself
and say
but this is what i need to say and this
is how i have to work him through this
so that was quite complex and frankly i
don't think anybody had the skills to do
other than me yeah so well being the
team captain you had so many jobs i
think i think you know people don't
really appreciate you know the amount of
effort and intentionality and just you
know the extent to which this
commandeered your entire life in your
family's life this was a family journey
but you being kind of captain of this
ship part of that responsibility is
given that you know james so well
knowing when it might be appropriate to
pull them aside and pull the plug on
this thing right if it's really going
south definitely
and at the same time
masking the severity of the situation
to james or towards james
to make sure that he doesn't get
discouraged because i'm the ultimate
optimist and i'm the ultimate problem
solver so if i showed any signs of
weakness or concern towards james it
would have completely demoralized him
so i had to maneuver and manage the
severity of certain situations behind
his back
without him seeing it or knowing it to
make sure that it didn't demoralize him
in this journey right you know that's a
very complex things especially where i'm
a very forthright person i'm not one to
just be like everything's okay you know
i'm i'm very forthright and so it was a
delicate balance of saying
you know what has to be addressed what
not and at the same time james didn't
listen to anything we said anyway
so you know
you know i said you know this is really
serious you're gonna die today he'd be
like that's great i've got things to do
you know so it was it was quite an
interesting balance yeah i was never
gonna die though no he was never gonna
die no but i mean when i think about
um
the difference between the hundred
versus the 50 50 50
as mind-blowing as the 50 50 50 was
a big portion of that was logistics and
managing chaos and all the crazy
variables that are baked into going from
state to state to state and the
difference with the 100 despite the fact
that it's twice the distance
is that you could implement systems and
minimize the amount of chaos to create
you know some level of predictability i
mean obviously when you're doing 100
iron distance trial ones there's going
to be
stuff that happens that you're not going
to foresee and we're going to get into
that
but
i'm interested in in your expectations
for you know how it would go versus how
it unfolded you know because you thought
like okay well i'm at home i'm going to
sleep in my bed every night i've got
this team around me we have a home base
i'm going to go out and do this one
thing and it's essentially going to be
the same every single day yeah let me
say this one thing first when before we
started i said i'm going to sit down
with the wingman james you're not
invited we're going to have a
conversation about some of the things
that were went wrong on the 15 how he
can change them and all of them were
tied to logistics yeah so going in
we were like we don't even know what to
worry about because everything from the
50 that was complex had to do with
logistics yeah and that was the whole
premise going into the 100 was okay if
the 50 truly was
chaos
logistics if we remove that can we
double what we did
and because the original goal going into
the 50 was how many consecutive can i do
what's my limit mentally and physically
and we settled on the 50 because it was
a cool project we threw in the logistics
and that became the kind of centerpiece
of the project and so with with uh years
removed from the project and having an
opportunity to now
you know covet happens my calendar gets
wiped clean right have an opportunity
you are on the speaking circuit yeah
basically traveling all over the place
and racing all three of those things got
shut down in 48 hours
and so i basically had a year to start
to prepare and get ready and we were
initially going to do the project uh in
the fall like right now
and i just kept getting the impression
march 1st do it march 1st starting march
1st and a lot of times with like
gut or intuition we don't know why in
the moment
and a lot of people will
not follow it because it's not logical
it doesn't make sense
and i sonny and i just we talked about
it and she was like well if you keep
getting the impression we've got to do
in march
and now looking back on it there's a lot
of reasons why march made way more sense
than it than than it did now but the
problem that it created
was
it upped the timetable six months and
physically
that's a big difference when you're
preparing for this when you have over
the past five years removed from the 50
become
out of shape and not ready and i was
really relying on
past experience and i also knew that
okay this
project is a quarter of a year and i'm
going to use the 100
the first half of it as training for the
back half
well you just can't anticipate the toll
that
you know that amount of volume is going
to do to your body yeah and right out of
the gate i just got riddled with
injuries and problematics and it was
just like now we got to solve these
problems right right because we decided
october
so that left that was the original
november december january february we
had four months was it yeah and you
didn't do a ton of running getting ready
for it right i did almost no running wow
none and if it was like 12 minute mile
on a treadmill if it was uh-huh yeah
okay so i was running max three days a
week
reason two i'd say two he says three two
maybe it was two
what was the reason for that were you
did you have uh some injuries that you
were dealing with with that or so i did
have an ankle injury that i didn't
vocalize um but i wasn't concerned about
it
because
my body is great at adapting and
evolving um just from a decade worth of
experience but for me the running is
the hardest on my body and always leads
to with any athlete that i coach running
is the biggest contributor to injury
and so i was like okay
if i can become super strong super
strong powerful on the bike
my i'm not going to be running fast my
body will adapt and evolve in the first
part of it well to go from running
okay two days a week right to
what's the quick math 26 times seven
yeah 140 miles a week
um
that's that's not a lot of weight
yeah that's the quickest way to get
injured that's his mind though right he
doesn't think
oh i'm gonna go from this to this he
says i have this idea and i'm going to
do it right right he doesn't i just
remember in the early i don't know you
know all the all the days kind of blur
together but it was definitely early in
in the conquest
where things were going sideways and
your mantra was this is the process like
this is the adaptation period and it
just looked like everything was
completely unraveling and you were
hobbling and it just was not and you're
like this we just have to get through
this phase until the body adapts and i
was like good luck with that man well i
we couldn't believe it like like
things things went sideways so fast
um and so early
um
like so early like not even a week like
right like
yeah
i'm in a lot of pain and i'm in a lot of
trouble but our team just doesn't quit
and that's the that's the interesting
part and we don't quit on each other and
so nobody like nobody was like hey we
should probably
dial this back we're just like okay
your ankle was like three times the size
i want to find that picture when i'm
sitting on the fireplace mantle and it
is just like you can't tell the
difference between my my quad and my
ankle well and part of why i'm laughing
so hard is because on the 50 i remember
six days in he's miserable and i'm like
oh he'll adapt like a day 10 the day
come 10 comes and i'm like oh he'll
adapt like day 15. and we're like today
30 and i'm just saying oh yeah his
body's going to adapt it's going to
adapt he just kept waiting
by the time we were on like day 85 we're
like why are we still dealing with foot
problems and blisters maybe it's because
you're getting up every day and doing an
iron distance triathlon yeah like i'm
not giving your body the ability to
adapt why are we so positive
i just remember sunny saying multiple
times
like with 20 to go everything like why
are we still dealing with this problem
why is this still a problem like we're
80 days into this we should have
overcome this by and so this if i was to
contrast the two the 50 and 100
the 50 was chaos logistics and fatigue
this one was injuries pain and longevity
and it just it just never let up
and so they had nothing in common
they were two very different projects on
the surface you're like oh consecutive
consecutive
very very very different excuse me
projects and we were dealing with very
different things on both of them and we
were in very different times of our
lives too and we're talking six months
from i mean six years removed from right
that accomplishment and that was the
biggest thing too is like leading into
the 50 we're talking a a consistent
decade worth of projects leading up to
it stepping stones growth
and then right into the next one well
then you
pause for six years because you're you
know providing for the family you're
speaking you're coaching you're
mentoring you're doing all these things
and then you're like oh let's just pick
up right where we left off
double it and try to and jesus thanks
and i'm like sweetheart what was the
original impetus for the idea like was
it because everything closed down or was
that was it already something that you
were planning on doing at some point
no i i had you know after the 50 i was i
was done like it was over like that i
was satisfied it was it was good and
um
we were just so busy we were so busy
with everything there wasn't an
opportunity to do what's next but i'd be
lying if i didn't say
i was always intrigued with
what's possible uh is there more once
you had time to reflect once i had time
to reflect but there really wasn't there
really wasn't an opportunity because
even if i wanted to carve it out like we
were booking our speaking well in
advance
and
and for me
you know
we we live a great life now and i was
like okay i'd have to shut this down for
right a year in order to actually see
that
thing is that right and now i've got
teenagers i got four daughters that
means four weddings my kids are starting
to go to university and i'm like i'm
looking at the costumes and i'm like i
don't i don't have the luxury to not
to stop doing this over here to try to
push my limits even further and the
pandemic really forced my hand in for
lack of a better phrase
but just really put the opportunity on
the table because
literally 48 hours
my entire calendar got wiped clean every
event canceled my bureau called me
they're like hey
we just had the entire year's worth of
events canceled your month of march was
i mean minute to minute he had six
weekends in a row of racing
it was packed so not only was a wipe
clean but it was
like i i was inconsolable because i was
like oh my gosh this is going to be an
intense six weeks and then gone yeah
but i love the perspective shift i mean
you can kind of wallow in misery and
self-pity over that or you can use the
pause to figure out how to level up and
one of the things that i didn't realize
about
the 50
was the extent to which you guys were
going through a very difficult kind of
financial time i mean i've gone through
something similar to that and using the
50 as a way like well here's what i can
do like things are not working out and
we're having trouble making ends meet
but i can do this one thing and there's
a there's kind of a big faith piece
there that if i do this
somehow the universe will conspire to
support me in a new and unique way
yeah oh
for sure
and the the
you always get asked what's your why
what's your purpose what's your reason
for doing something
and people always ask too well why
didn't you quit or how do you keep going
and on the 50 like our reasons were so
strong like it was get our lives back
um
change the direction of our lives and
quitting wasn't on the table
and then
to to contrast that to the hundred and
the reasons why you're doing it are very
very different like were
established in like it was a huge dice
roll for me to double it because now i'm
risking
the criticism that we took on the 50
like you don't make it past 50
so that you know that really rings true
on when you just said on week one things
start to go sideways and you're like i'm
risking my entire career and decades
worth of work
for this new project that i don't have
to do
because now the reasons that i was doing
the 50 are very different than they are
doing now and this tr this the hundred
was truly
what am i capable of mentally and
physically because we've
career-wise there there wasn't a huge
uptake there wasn't a huge like benefit
to doing it like i was already
established in my speaking career we've
already got the book the documentary
everything's going great
and so it was really like well why are
you doing this
yeah like what is what's the risk reward
to what you're doing what's the answer
to that
why did i do it for me it was personal
yeah absolutely it was it was redemption
i believe a lot a part of it was
redemption for me well you had told me
uh that part of it was motivated by
sort of silencing the the critics
because there was a little bit of
mumbling about the 50 because of
circumstances etc a bunch of nonsense
yeah so it was about putting that to
rest there was there was definitely a
huge huge part of that for me personally
and
a big part of my platform is like look
don't listen to the grumblings the
haters don't give them any power
and at the same time i was like
they're eating me live they're reading
me alive and do you flip that coin and
say well
is there a little bit of reason to what
they're saying and are they you know and
you really have to have that that's a
that's a hard conversation to have with
yourself like balancing and reckoning
those
those thoughts and okay is what they're
saying truth and is there some validity
to it
and you know over the course of five
years of speaking and on stages you
start to
you get off a stage and you post
something that you didn't it's just one
one person says something online
and you're like well am i a hypocrite
did i really do what i said i did am i
presenting what i truly believe and then
i had this opportunity when the 2020
like i have an opportunity to reset
history and when we were on the course
of the 100
man day 51 was huge for me
well i even had little landmarks too
right so make it past 18 when you
crashed your bike fell asleep and
crashed on your bike make it past day 19
when you
got on the elliptical right you make it
past that you're like okay i've reset
that piece of my history i've reset that
piece of my history that's no longer on
the table and then you make it past 50
and now you're 51 and every day you wake
up you got to break a new world record
and then that becomes fun right and so
there was for me there was a
this was the tale of two halves there
was so much pressure on me personally
that i put on myself to make it back to
right because you don't you don't you
don't get to 51
and you personally discredited
everything you've done in the past
because if you if they didn't think you
did it the first time you certainly
didn't do it the second time if you fail
and so for me on my journey that first
50 was like so important to me and i
remember having conversations with aaron
on the bike every single day okay this
day means this this day means this once
we make it past here and the back half
became
every day just like this is who we
thought we were and who we said we were
and we're sure
here in in sharing that is this idea of
setting an audacious goal but the path
towards accomplishing
something that is seemingly impossible
is to break it down into these little
chunks i mean it's truly about what
you're doing in the moment and there's a
broader conversation that we can we can
have about being present and the
mindfulness that you have to bring to
each moment and just focusing on what
you have to accomplish in
you know the next day the next hour
whatever it is but having those little
benchmarks and then allowing yourself to
celebrate them
is the fuel that keeps you engaged with
something that you know otherwise is
just too overwhelming to even process
well
two different things one um
that moment happened early on like when
you said looking from the outside
looking in that things went sideways it
was probably about day 15 when when my
shin was at the peak of its pain the
first shin problem was at the peak of
its pain and literally every step i took
i thought i was going to break my leg
and i just continued to manage it and i
remember finishing one day it was
probably around 15
and i said to sonny that night i said
hey i don't i don't think i can manage
that level of pain for 85 more days
something has to give
and
full knowing that something maybe wasn't
going to give sonny just said hey look
and this is the best advice i got on the
entire hundred
she said hey the work is done today do
you remember this one of course i do
okay it happened more than once yeah she
said i remember the one but she's a
truth bomb because because i was like
hey i just
like i would kind of just shrug my
shoulders and just complete um totally
demoralizing i was totally demoralized
totally dejected because i was the one
that was managing the pain and i
couldn't i couldn't
like
voice voice how much i was dealing with
and
i don't think you could even conceive it
because your mind wasn't even i mean
there was
so much dissonance in the mind in the
body right no and so i remember saying i
don't i can't manage that level of pain
for 85 more days because i knew what
that took
and she said
you don't have to the work is done today
and and i was like well she's like just
trust in your team let us take care of
you tonight you're done today he's in
the shower knows that he said you're in
a hot shower cause it was freezing right
it was cold too
you're dealing with so much though
and so
and she said we have no idea what
tomorrow is going to bring you could
feel totally different tomorrow now i
feel like crap the next day
but
we did turn corners and that that became
for me the mantra of the entire campaign
was
do the work today do everything you can
allow the team to take care of you and
then let's face tomorrow when tomorrow
comes
and then for me
deeper into the campaign
back to you know what we were just
talking about about how we had those
benchmarks in the first half was really
me
resetting history or my history um
slow twitch has been one of the the
biggest
haters yeah of course the slow twitch
forum is not uh it's not a friendly
place it's not a friendly pace place and
i mean they were ruthless towards me and
i've actually had the owner of slow
twitch reach out to me recently and
wants to sit down
um which i'll do herbert
yeah yeah which i'll do um but there was
a point in the hundred where aaron had
gone on aaron's one of the wingmen and
he had gone on to slow twitch and
he said hey they have started a forum
that says
um
james james has
done it
and this thread is nothing but
positivity
about it and in that moment when aaron
came and said that i was like
i freaking turned slow how many days how
many days in were you at oh well past
halfway right
60s or something
for
that was like the last like
thing for me to reset my history around
unfinished business for me it was like
hey slow twitch has started a positive
form about you and i'm like whoa
that's amazing yeah yeah yeah you know
so that was kind of my moment it's no
small thing for anybody who's familiar
with that yeah
exactly and so those kind of two moments
for me were really pivotal that
conversation was sunny early early on
where i was completely broken
couldn't conceptualize 85 more and then
fast forward all the way to where we'd
reset history we'd we made it past all
of those personal benchmarks of mine and
then slow choice starts a
positive only form about the iron cowboy
who has been their biggest target for
years and years and years so
obviously sonny you know this is a
family decision so
did james come to you with this idea did
you concoct this together like what does
that look like as a family with five
kids
when 14 weeks are gonna be monopolized
by this endeavor and it's gonna take
everything that all of you guys have and
you've got kids who are living their own
lives and need attention and care like
how does all of that work because if
there is
you know a sliver of of criticism i was
like oh they're you know they're this is
selfish and they're you know they're
they're shirking their responsibilities
with their kids and all of that and like
as somebody's who knows you guys and
visited twice during this event and
um
you know bore witness to what was going
on like this was a family adventure
completely like all your kids are in i
mean you know lucy i mean forget about
it we could do a whole podcast on on how
amazing she was throughout this whole
thing but what did that look like as a
family decision and as a family affair
we had
conversed and
researched some other projects
so a couple years after the 50 james was
like you know
i kind of have some ideas and so we kind
of researched some ideas and there's a
lot of pressure from sponsors i mean
what's biggest question what's next
what's next what's next and he's a
dreamer so you know his mind is always
brewing
so we thought about all these different
ideas and they weren't really working
and um
james has a lot of ideas
you guys only see what happens so as we
kind of went through these ideas jake
paul or something sure why not
let's go where's mcgregor where are you
where's my hundred million for the bike
i'm due for a payday rich
so we had kind of explored these
different ideas but i hadn't gotten all
caught up in them because you have to
there's so much complexity to preparing
them that my mind was open to ideas but
i wasn't necessarily
concerned about the investment yet
and then as they continued to fall
through and oh these aren't going to
work the way we thought would
he
said to me one day early in that year
maybe may he's like you know i just keep
thinking about doing a hundred foals
and i was like really
because he had
he had kind of not been soured but had
been turned off by the 50 just because
it had been so intense that i was
surprised that he was going to consider
something
in that same type of realm but even
harder
so i was like oh that's interesting you
know and then a week later comes back
he's like no i really can't stop
thinking about it so we kind of talked
about it for a couple weeks and finally
i said if you can't stop thinking about
it
that's god telling you to do it which
makes no sense i mean
everything james has ever done in his
life makes no sense including sitting on
a ferris wheel for 10 days you know it's
like there's no there's no logic to
james's goals and dreams and aspirations
so he's like i'm going to kind of dangle
a carrot talk to some sponsors kind of
feel it out do a little research and see
how i can maybe make this work out and
how it would be received yeah how will
it be received how much support i could
get you know if it really is something
that could work and so in august he said
hey it's gonna work everybody's in
and when you realize how long it is then
you're saying okay my gosh how are we
gonna how are we gonna fit this into a
four season year in utah we've got four
seasons so he said i'm either going to
catch an early snow or i'm going to
catch um i mean a late snow in the
spring or an earlier snow in the fall
and so we are less likely to have an
early snow in the fall
and if you do it's just going to be a
one day thing and melt so we kind of
established the idea of starting in
august doing august september october
and utah we have a lot of sunshine in
the winters and you know we don't get
snow till later in the year so we're
like this is going to be great
and then he comes to me and says
hey i keep feeling like we should do
this in march
i was like march
he's like yeah march 1st
i'm like really
so i kind of sat out for a couple days
and then i looked at my calendar and i
was like you can't do it march
i mean i had the entire spring planned
out
from my 40th birthday to spring break to
all of these things on this calendar and
i was like james if you do this in march
it's going to completely disrupt my ear
it quickly came don't talk to me about
this until after thanksgiving and after
christmas
then i'll process yeah like so i said
he's like okay and then he kind of came
back again he's like i just like what
she did at march and i was like oh my
gosh right now this moment i hate you
for this
because james is a person of conviction
and he's not going to come to me and say
i think we should do this unless he
actually thinks we should do it he's
he's not bluffing on stuff like that
that's just on his personality if he's
passionate about something there's
something to it
so i was like i hate you right now
because i know this must be the right
thing to do but it's going to ruin my
life
so this was like in november
our anniversary is at the beginning of
december and
our 20th he
he's like
[Applause]
putting in little blurbs like you know
this and that and i was like i don't
want to talk about it like i have to
process this like this is really going
to mess my year up and so our
anniversary came we are obviously
stressed out our mind playing with 100 i
said we got to do something it's our
20th we always travel but obviously last
year was different with coveted and
everything so we just did a staycation
in park city
and we got to dinner
and he's like i can't do this without
your support
so you're telling me we can do it but i
know the support's not there i know you
have don't have your own conviction or
whatever and so i was like you just need
to give me time to process this
i did a lot of praying
and within two weeks i was like okay i'm
all in he's like you're all in shocked
right oh my gosh you're all in are you
sure you're all in i'm like i'm all in
because at that point i had my own
conviction like god had told me myself
this was the right thing to do
i knew
and so i just cancelled everything it
was like the year was canceled because i
knew from march to june
i mean we had
easter and graduation and birthdays and
i mean just so many things that i i was
like okay i'll do the best i can to
prepare for these before we start going
so far as to packing easter eggs and
preparing all the baskets and putting
them in my closet
so that when it came because with the 50
there were a lot of promises of it's
going to be this great adventure it's
going to be super easy blah blah and
then it was complete havoc so i'm like i
know the idea is that this will be
simpler because we're at home but the
reality is i know that won't really
happen so i was trying to plan
everything i could before we started
but then i knew i knew it was go time
and i knew so whenever james would
struggle
i knew it's what we were supposed to be
doing
and so i just always looked for a way
through it he couldn't do that because
his mind wasn't there so my job was to
be the sound mind to that experience and
to rely on the faith that i knew it's
what we were supposed to be doing and to
seek solutions and to be all in i mean
it was all-consuming i mean your house
was completely taken over
it's two huge lessons the day of
atonement james right now but really i
wasn't going to try to find balance it
was not appropriate
the balance would come later that 100
days was about this project it was about
james's project i knew i would have my
time later there was no need for balance
it was literally just dive in and go for
it
well when she signs off and says i'm all
in i immediately panic because when she
goes all in it's all in and then i
realize
yeah it's official and i'm like now i
only have four months to get ready for
this and i'm nowhere near close
physically is that march start date i
mean it was so early i mean i'm watching
this on instagram and i'm like it's
snowing every day
it's freezing day one was 18. you keep
thinking like well just maybe a couple
more days of this and it'll get nice out
and and that winter just extended you
know well i saw how the heat affected
you at the end so i understand the logic
of that obviously you do better in cold
than in heat well and if you look now
the fires that we're dealing with
like utah has literally the worst air
quality in the world right now and this
would be the month two of three months
of doing it yeah
we'd be dealing with the heat and
literally one week after we finished on
june 8th or june 9th um 107 degrees
outside pavement temperature was 120.
wow one week after yeah that would have
buried yeah oh it just would have
completely well and the other part was
is that the family was occupied right so
it didn't consume their summer so the
kids were still in school my job was to
make sure they were still living their
life feeling like
they could just be themselves and enjoy
this journey and so they were still in
school they were still working they were
still doing their normal things and they
just enjoyed the hundred they jumped in
where they wanted to and they enjoyed it
except for the time it was beautiful
yeah i think this became a full-time job
but she wanted that crushed it she did i
i want to say quickly too for the
listeners that that maybe don't know us
is we we have five kids
and four daughters one son and during
the campaign they were ages 11 through
18. and so i just for the for the new
listener yeah yeah
and lucy of course was the project
manager of swords and james's assistant
and ran all the social media that's like
her dream job though so although her
stress level was like to the max
oh man that's exactly where she wanted
to be did she she ended up getting a job
out of this right like any brand who was
watching well she had a job offer from
visa as an apprentice and i was like no
no no she's mine so i've hired her full
time yeah
so let's talk a little bit about some of
the obstacles you faced i mean you
alluded to the shin problem and the
ankle problem early on that got
ameliorated by this brace like this
custom kind of carbon fiber thing that
you got at some point that allowed you
to offload some of the pressure on your
shin yeah i think any
journey especially if you
a longer journey
to be successful and any anybody that's
been on a journey will say that there
was a little bit of luck involved
and this brace situation was a whole lot
of luck or jesus a bit of both um it
just so happens the number one guy in
the country that makes custom carbon
braces for ankle and chin problems
lived
off of the trail that we were running on
like he had just moved there and one of
the cyclists in london
yeah wow one of the cyclists that joined
us is an orthopedic surgeon
that refers all of his post surgery
clients to this
outfit
and so i was on the run one day and he
he obviously got wind that we were
struggling and my shin was bothering and
he says hey have you ever considered
a carbon plated shin brace it's an
insole for your shoe the brace just
holds it to the leg but it's a carbon
insole to absorb the shock
and i said i don't even know what that
is so i obviously haven't considered
haven't considered it he goes let me
talk to my guy what it is is it's a
carbon like sonny just said a carbon
plate that goes on the bottom of your
shoe
that they fit custom and then it's got a
bar that goes up the side or the front
depending on the
how strong you want to be and then and
then it anchors on the top of your calf
essentially that carbon plate and the
anchor point with the bar completely
offloads that shin and allows it to heal
and i said well can people walk in and
he goes people can run in them
and he goes the first version we'll put
you in will completely offload it it's
pretty restrictive you'll be limited to
walking but as we see and if we see
progress we can get you into a running
brace
and so we started with that one and he
would meet me at each one of those
intersections off the trail and he's
like do you have any like he just said
these are normally custom but we're
gonna give one to you i've got one and
we'll have to we'll have to tool it and
tweak it as we progress and so he'd give
it to me i'd put it on he goes the goal
is to have no touch points on your leg
and i was like okay it's touching here
and here and he would take it into the
back of his van and he would machine
tool it and he would like quickly get to
the other intersection before i got
there and we'd like put this on and we
did that over the course of 26 miles
and by the end of that day we had a
brace that was somewhat custom to me but
it wasn't touching any part of my shin
relieving all pain
and allowing me to progress
and so then every single day we would we
would go through and manage the level of
pain that i was having and where this
brace was touching and we would tweak it
and he'd come out on different days and
make sure we were still progressing and
i ended up being in that brace for three
or four weeks
and then we upgraded to the the more
flexible one
um which allowed me to to run some
sections in it
and it was just
it was the thing that allowed us to
continue because i
like i said you told me that it was so
painful you literally thought you were
going to snap your leg and you were
willing to snap it you're like i'm going
to snap my leg before i quit this thing
yeah it was going to get to the point
where that that it was going to snap and
that's what was going to make that allow
it would be the only circumstances
it was going to be the it was going to
be the narrative that the public would
say okay
that is unacceptable
that's adjustable and acceptable reason
to stop anything short of that
you using you know you're a quitter and
i obviously don't want that
and so
that that brace saved it because it'll
it'll literally allow that stress
fracture to
heal while doing a full marathon
every single day including the the bike
miles now
what came with that
was the imbalance that it created which
lightning bolted up into my hip which
then was the next thing and that this
project became like i said
injury and management of injury and it
was this trickle effect or
um
what's it called
uh one thing leads to a domino effect
yeah like a domino effect of of injury
because it started with the ankle went
up into the shin
you know we dealt with that and we
figured it out once we moved up through
the body and i just remember like i was
like i have no shin pain today and we're
like okay we're clear we can go
and
the next day my hip just exploded like
stopped me in my tracks and i remember
my therapist hayden he was like can we
not get one day
where we're not dealing with something
and it just became this domino effect of
i was always dealing with something yeah
like the busted up feet were the
relief it was like oh good today you're
just missing the whole bottom of your
foot with skin
sorely this is it today you know you're
looking at his foot thinking how does
your foot look like this 85 days in yet
we're celebrating this because this is
all it is right right right right it's
all it's all perspective yeah you know
yeah um you told me some crazy stories
about the sleep
disruption
yes i mean that just sounds terrifying
it was because you know outside looking
in
someone says oh okay he's done the 140
miles today he can now go rest and
recover
well that was the second side of that
coin or that journey right so on the
outside looking in you're like okay he's
doing the swim the bike the run 2.4 112
26.
and then they're like okay complexities
continued okay he gets to go home and
sleep and rest well no as soon as i got
home when i had to refuel two it's two
to three hours of
pretty intense therapy on the table yeah
you're on the massage table trying to
immediately sleep honestly you're eating
while they're working managing problems
solving problems
the the house is chaos because
everybody's there trying to do stuff
that's an understatement yeah yeah and
then once once everybody leaves and the
therapy's done it was around 11 00 p.m
midnight most nights i'd move into my
bed and then my second wave of like
managing things would would start and
the three biggest things that we dealt
with was
incredible hot sweats like we're talking
sweating through
duvets and i mean like
sweating like you've never seen and then
and then that that leads to uh
dehydration problems you know and and
and trying to keep yourself hydrated um
panic attacks panic attacks night
terrors
which
finally went away well the hypebrake
chamber
after a while we're like you can't sleep
in there because you can't just get out
right if he's freaking out
we can't get to him he can't get out it
was it was wild and and kind of not
really just being able to get a restful
night of sleep yeah right like despite
the extraordinary fatigue and you're
laying there on there
or whatever with normative boots on
falling asleep like you're sweating and
yeah having and weren't you doing some
sleepwalking too
uh there's some stories oh yeah yeah
there's great stuff
the kids have some pretty funny stories
i loved it that was the highlight of the
100 i guess there was one time i went
upstairs to just check on my daughters
and i had no idea and i i one time i was
wandering outside the house and dolly
was coming home from something and she
was wondering what i was doing i didn't
i didn't realize it and they were saying
hey what were you doing outside last
night and i was like i was in my bed
last night yeah so these these kind of
crazy stories
like what is going on physiologically
that would cause that right why i mean
have you talked to anybody like you
should hook up with like matt walker and
have him figure out like what was going
on with you or what precipitated like
that kind of strange
yeah and i don't i don't even know how
you quantify it or
or like study it now yeah um literally
when i go home tomorrow i'm i go to a
brain mri
um to where because i've been dealing
with brain fog and depression and
fatigue and things like that
yeah for sure
um and i have good moments and bad
moments and
it depends on how much like
mental energy i have to expend
throughout a day right now
but there'll be a point of the day where
if i've done a lot i'd be like sonny i
think i need to just like rest or like i
need you to drive home right after the
that's my favorite story right after 50
i was driving down the freeway
like at the finish line leaving the
finish line yeah was this leaving yes
because i was stuck with you everybody
left
we had all this stuff and all these cars
and no one to drive them home so james
had to drive the van home
from the finish line of the 50 with all
the bikes on the back oh i'm thinking of
doing a story oh there's more than one i
get pulled over by the police on the way
home from the 50.
um and just had to have an interesting
conversation with the police but the one
i'm talking about was after the hundred
the hundred was over
i'm sorry i meant the hundred uh brain
fog yeah
yeah i'm driving down the freeway and
sunny looks over to me and she goes
sweetheart you're going 45 miles an hour
and i was like oh okay yeah i'll pick it
up a little bit and he did for
five minutes and then i was like
sweetheart because i see now you're
going 50. and i remember saying
i remember saying this is a lot faster
than we were going on my bike right you
know but you just you know slip into
these you know bits of brain fog and so
right when i get home i'm super
fortunate again one of the only places
in the united states that does this kind
of study and testing for concussion and
and um tbi yeah yeah post traumatic
stuff
is in utah and they actually put you
into an mri they set up all the scans
and then they ask you a series of
questions
and it's designed to light up every part
of your brain once they take you through
the whole protocol and then they can see
where blood flow isn't going which
pathways are blocked and what's going on
and then they put you through an
extensive um 30 hour protocol based on
the results that resets and re-patterns
your brain turns it back on and so this
is like super exciting for me like
professional like a lot of football
players will go there from across the
country nfl players or our car accidents
concussion people
people that are showing like signs of
alzheimer's and things like that will go
uh to this cognitive therapy place in
provo and uh and i'm just
so so you haven't been there yet you're
going to go wherever when i land i go
from the airport to get those mri scans
and then based on the results we'll
start the therapy to kind of like reset
my brain but when you finished you did
you came down to ucla like shortly after
you completed the 100 and had a bunch of
tests and run i mean what were the what
was the upshot of that yeah so we had
kind of a baseline testing done at ucla
prior to and they were mostly looking at
like cardiovascular heart lungs things
like that the size of it what it does
under stress
mris that way
and then they wanted to see okay if you
put your body through what the human
body can do with with you know 14 000
miles
and then go and get stress test done did
we did we create like heart murmurs did
we create a rhythmic problems did we
create all these things that we did
damage to the body
and as sonny and i have known the body's
an amazing
piece of machinery
um they we completely stumped the
cardiovascular world and these the
cardiologists and they were like
you're you're fitter and stronger and
you've done zero damage to your heart
and you didn't you like break the record
yeah
yeah we already broke the
last record
just because i became such a
solid cyclist
you do you do hundreds and then you like
after a couple weeks of break you got
back on the bike and we're crushing some
kom's around yeah
i pr around around our neighborhood and
some of the climbs that we do and for me
it was more like getting out was more
mental than anything um just because
sitting at home and focusing on the
fatigue and i'm tired and i'm depressed
and all that that just magnifies the
problem
and so for me getting out with
i mean the cycling community really came
out on the 100 and so i had i had
developed a lot of really great
friendships um
just
we'd sit on the bike for six seven hours
a day and just talk
to these new people and this the
community really came out and said this
is our project too we're protecting you
we're gonna get you through this
and then a lot of the cyclists went
through the same thing i did they would
come out two three times a week for a
quarter of a year and then like
overnight that goes away
and they're like well where's our group
rides and where's that camaraderie and
where's you know we've we've missed that
and so for me getting back out was great
for me it was great for the community it
was great for those people that had
their
their journey alongside our journey yeah
a lot of people are struggling i mean
covet happened and the world shut down
and a lot of depression and anxiety
happened
and utah happened to be one of the
states and from the outside looking in
where like we we had still an
opportunity to go outside and do stuff
and and it was really great and a lot of
those people before
you know we just come out of winter and
so people have been trapped inside and
coveted and no families and a lot of
people lost jobs and so this was a
project where it kind of like gave a lot
of people hope and purpose alongside of
what we were doing
this is the real story behind the story
there's a lot of focus on how did you do
the the 100 and like the particulars of
that and the family you know journey
that that that that you know entailed
but truly it's the community piece and
you know it was
so impactful to visit and see not only
like your town come out and support i
mean it's like such a beautiful
expression of solidarity all these
people who
were just there for you guys in in every
which way and then on top of that
all these people who flew in or drove in
from
all parts of the country all parts of
the world i met people from eastern
europe who you know flew out to
have this experience to share this
experience with you people who are
inspired by what what you were doing and
what you were sharing online and just so
many lives transformed and i think that
gets to this piece about
um
finding the the blessings and the
misfortunes like the fact that you
were compelled to walk actually made it
more accessible for a lot of people and
i think brought a a larger you know it
was achieved
yeah yeah yeah and became something that
people could wrap their heads around
like joining you for a long walk
it was so beautiful yeah that part of it
yeah i can't tell you how many times
every single day one casey would do kind
of a roll count on who who's
who's here where are you from and casey
did a great job at like including
everybody talking because i a lot of
days i wasn't in a good head space to do
it and i really really focus on what
their job i mean i spent a lot of time
talking to those guys like their job is
to protect you like keep you
because you're gonna get some you know
some wacky people too who who you know
are vying for your attention and their
job is to like make sure that there's a
buffer
around you so that you yeah you can say
hello but like you gotta focus on what
you're trying to do and that was the
amazing the amazing part was casey would
do the roll call every single day and
then we'd start to hear about other
people's stories and one where they came
from but then throughout the day
you know we would that was one of the
coolest things for me to experience was
people did give me my distance um and
respect what i was going through and
um
yeah i just just respected that but what
was a lot of fun was
for you know five six hours on the on
the walk run you could hear
the chatter and the people talking and
sharing their stories and the subgroups
and
it just people that would have never
crossed paths before
and every single day without fail um we
had somebody say or we heard hey we
wouldn't we wouldn't have been able to
participate in this we wouldn't have
been able to experience this had jameson
running
um
and it was it was just one of the the
coolest things that happened was the one
you know you said community community
was huge
but two
my my pain and suffering and injury
became a blessing to so many other
people that badly wanted to be part of
what we were doing but otherwise
wouldn't have had an opportunity to do
so and we were just talking at lunch
about um this five-year-old kid who had
just turned six do you know this sorry
um i don't know yes little chances oh i
do yeah but of course so yeah it's a
really cool story and this kid um says
you know he's he was a neighbor of
casey's and the dad said okay we'll go
out because the kid really wanted to do
part of the walk with us
and and people don't realize we were
walking at a pretty decent pace
and a lot of we if we did take a
criticism from the the elites it was
that we were walking
and um i had to run i couldn't walk that
fast yeah we were like
we were walking there to get a clip and
we blew a lot of people i was falling
off the people off a lot of times i'm
like yeah he's moving pretty good like i
got a job i got to start running here to
catch back up and so this this little
kid
just got inspired and motivated and said
i want to go do a couple miles with the
iron cowboy and the dad was like okay
we'll get your shoes we'll get your
shorts on we'll go out we'll pick our
day and he he did he knocked out three
miles with us
and then his dad was like okay we're
done we did the 5k and he's like no the
iron cowboy's still going i want to keep
going with him
and you could see him as we started to
progress and and do more miles he really
started to struggle
but this kid had
zero quit in him just bawling he was
just he was starting to cry he was in so
much pain he was just in so much pain he
ended up knocking out 20 miles
that night it's crazy 20 minutes
because he's a little bad
you think of a five-year-old kid yeah
right off the couch did knocks out 20
miles
and then was just so upset
his dad ended up telling us that he was
so upset that he wasn't able to finish
with us
because he just couldn't go any further
and so they plotted out another day
and
he started before us while we were still
on the bike and he knocked out five or
six or seven miles and then we
eventually caught him and he stayed with
us the rest of the time and this five
six-year-old kid ended up doing a full
marathon
with us and it was just one of the most
unbelievable experiences and we
were with someone at lunch and they had
just said
he he hadn't been taught yet
um to quit and it wasn't part of his
culture and so like it begs the question
like when in our adult journey did like
was that is that a taught thing
is that when did it become acceptable
when did that be part of our culture
because that kid was just like no well
i'm in a lot of pain but i i want to do
this and i'm going to endure
until i finally finished he just balling
you know a lot of parents are swinging
in and rescuing this kid and
shawn let him
sean let him fight through those tears
sean let him finish like that's as
beautiful of a story as it is that
chase gutted it yeah and his sense of
personal possibility now is yeah very
different than it was before that but
that's just one i mean he's the youngest
but there were so many people who showed
up who had never done anything before or
were coming off of you know crazy weight
loss stories and also a lot of first
marathons yeah i think i think
the power in what you were doing was
that
it normalized something that seems
impossible to most people and just to
see you doing it day after day after day
and the walking piece
made it accessible to people and so
they're like well maybe i'll show up and
i'll do a little bit and then they end
up doing a little bit longer than they
thought they would and before they all
come tomorrow and i'll and then they're
doing like a whole marathon and they're
people who are doing the full ironman
yeah like people who would never sign up
for an official iron man
showing up and doing the full thing
because they see you doing it every
single day and suddenly it seems maybe
not as hard as they thought it might be
we just sent out
hundreds of shirts
because what we said to people is like
you said hey come join us and if you do
all swim all bike i'll run with us when
this is over we'll send everybody that
finish to finish a shirt and they
finally came in
and we literally i mean lucy's probably
still packaging them up right now but
we've we sent out hundreds of they did
the full
full full with us hundreds yeah
we had four four full boxes show up i
mean we ran out of bags and i counted
how many shirts we didn't have bags for
and it was 50. wow and that was after we
ran out of shipping bats yeah so yeah
and so that many people and most of them
it was their first like they just and we
had people that would show up and like
okay day 15 they're gonna do part of the
bike ride and see how the pacing goes
and then they showed up and did part of
the run they would see who was finishing
the full triathlon and they were like
well fat guy can do it i can do it yeah
yeah if that girl we had i mean clint a
15 year old kid came out and did had no
like triathlon background at all he had
no clips on his shoes yeah he bought a
bike two weeks before or something and
he's fallen over at intersections he was
so exhausted it was so fun to see him
out these kids
hunter sweden he's just graduating he's
lucy's age and he's had a really rough
upbringing and he lost 70 pounds was
doing 75 heart and this was his last
final project he did a full triathlon
and he finished it two o'clock in the
morning well after the group had
finished what about the uh i forget his
name the hispanic guy takashi yeah all
right yeah
yeah he just broke swimming
never ran got it out that full thing he
just posted a picture as proud as can be
with his conquered shirt on he's the
most delightful person on this planet uh
safe how do you say his name safe yeah
yeah safe
yeah from india who india by way of
dallas like a phd student yeah who
literally
move like he was he just set up shop in
linden and he was doing his classes
remotely yeah and showed up for the
marriage he finished yesterday after day
his last day was several days before we
finished but
he was borderline hysterical the finish
line like he just sat and hugged me and
cried and cried and cried his life is
forever true he said this has changed my
life forever and we have and another
really cool story is an individual that
followed us
before the 50 through the 50 was a
massive supporter no josh powell oh josh
powell and josh said my goal by the end
of this campaign is to be able to
complete one marathon with you guys
and he start he would he would start way
before us and he'll still get dropped
and he'd get dropped and couldn't finish
and by the end of it he did the last i
think weeks worth of marathons with us
he did a full
a marathon a day for seven days over the
last part and was with us and he just
was so proud had the biggest smile on
his face but he he literally couldn't
finish a 10k with us when he started
yeah
and just he just showed up every single
day he's got a special needs daughter
and he would set up aid stations for us
and she was out there cheering for us
single dad with um full uh you know
special needs daughter and he was just
like this is a goal of mine i'm going to
do this with you guys i'm going to give
you all the support you need it's
stories like that and seth and
alex who followed us on the 50
and then came out and did his first full
marathon i think he started four hours
before and his goal is just to finish
the marathon yeah and he finished 10
minutes after 10 minutes after us and
which is balling yeah i'm just
just these stories and those are just
the stories of the people that we got to
interact with
on
you know on site we discussed the
hundreds of messages globally that came
in and said hey
because of your journey it has given me
hope on my journey and this is what i'm
struggling with and uh individuals hey i
was i was about to take my own life and
your journey started and it's given me
hope and i'm fighting again
all i mean just
you wonder why
you know for me personally i wonder why
i do things like this and
i joke that my gift is the ability to
suffer
and there's not a lot of benefit to
having this this gift and then we
receive literally hundreds of messages
from around the world of these people
that
that say your suffering has given me
hope on the journey that i'm on and that
is just like soul shaking
enough that we remember receive those
names we remember experiences yeah it's
really beautiful i mean there was a
sense of that with the 50 every state
that you were in it seemed like you
would pick up a few more people than the
day prior and there was like a momentum
thing that was happening that culminated
with you doing the final one
um
you know in in in utah and all the
people that showed up for that i mean
that was like bananas
so you had to have some sense that
you could replicate that on some level
but i think just being in the same place
every single day created this like force
field like a like a tractor beam right
that was attracting all of these people
who knew they could just show up yeah
it's like hey you know people like she
got on a plane this morning and can't
you know it was wild it was wild yeah it
was wild and and we
we didn't know what to expect because
travel restrictions and covet and all
that and i i just every single day
um
what shocked me more was the cycling
community that came out um
and then and then the likes sunny would
do a live every single day on the swim
and then she'd give me a rundown of the
different countries that were live that
day and then we started shipping out
shirts countries were shipping
yeah and
poland yeah iceland and we're just like
some country i'm really good with
geography and there's some countries and
i'm like i gotta look that up
like i've never had to look at country
and i think for i think for me and what
people need to realize is
you never know who's watching
and you never know who you can who
you're going to or who you can impact
and we had no idea that our small family
and the journey that and the crazy
adventures that we do would end up being
this global type of impact
and and changing the way people think
about the journey that they're on and
that was that's so humbling you know
when you think of this how big the world
is and to to
and and the reach that social media has
yeah nowadays
yeah who needs media coverage yeah i
know social media
it's all it's just so powerful i mean it
was like i mean i would just every day
like okay what's going on you know and
it would there was something about the
consistency of it like this metronome
like okay here's when like you climbing
out of the pool every day and putting
the crocs on i was like okay i can start
my day now like he's out of the pool
we put the crocs on you know like i can
go like out and do my thing he's like i
gotta see the crocs before i can like
legitimately go out into the world he
told me he's like this james it's a swim
towel i get a mouthful for christmas
each other names and people
you know we're like wait what happened
you changed the james tell me because
james said it's not absorbent enough i
wanted to run towel and then everybody
freaked out whoa whoa whoa
like really jamestown so i hung a good
towel in the bathroom and still wrapped
him in that jamestown because as as
normal and his routine things needed to
be for us i think people started to
expect this certain routine
yeah
the towel and me roll you know lucy
waiting for me to roll in off the bike
and they just expect these moments every
single day right yeah you got to capture
that as long as you get that one thing
every day like that's a that's an
important piece in the story that needs
to be told every day which is funny
because it was totally not the same for
us every day sure but that created an
illusion of normal normalcy normalcy
exactly um adam skolnik told me that you
know when he was down kind of like
hanging out with you guys and he did the
swim
on either the second to last day or
whatever it was
that i mean you did i i don't know what
you what did you you you just you broke
it up into a set of hundreds every day
right so that the swim would be
essentially exactly 4300
but
you would kind of come into the wall and
then everyone would wait for you to go
like there's a weird like cult thing to
that like okay james is pushing off we
can push off now
it was amazing and i
i had to stand a certain way in the pool
or i would immediately cramp up
and so i had to be very particular with
where i stood how i stood how i pushed
off of each wall and it just so happened
we were on the far south lane and all
the other lanes were to the north of us
and it just so happened i had to stand
facing south so i never saw any of this
type of activity because i always had to
have my back to everybody else that was
there so well he wasn't the first
swimmers the first swimmer is kind of on
you know the right side
he's waiting here to get his turn to go
to the other lane to head so he wasn't
even in position to face everybody and
then i saw some of the coolest footage i
had ever seen um it was a drone and it
was on day 100 when
all lanes were filled and we would i i'd
push off and all of a sudden all lanes
would start to move and it was this like
giant snake
and then when i'd stop everyone would
come in and stop and then we'd get going
again it was just this really cool and
he says that and i'm like i saw that
every day you didn't see that yeah and i
never saw it until i you know
once you start to break something down
and look back on it you start to see
footage and stuff because when you're in
the middle of it like i everyone's like
oh my gosh sonny's closet talk so you've
seen these and i'm like no no you're
riding your bike yeah i have no idea
what you guys are talking about like oh
sonny's closest hot goes epic today and
i'm like okay he's like what is the
closet what's a closet talk and they're
like the wing man blah blah and i'm like
what are you guys talking about and it
was all these things that became normal
to everybody else that i had no idea
what's happening right because like the
wingman breakdown happened when i was
getting therapy the closet talk happened
when
so all these things would happen that i
had no idea so when i saw that really
cool footage of that snake that you were
talking about and and that everybody
would push off the same time as me i was
like that's really cool
we'll be back in a sec but first if you
dig this podcast and i hope you dig this
podcast then i think you'll really enjoy
my latest book voicing change featuring
excerpts from poignant essays by and
glorious photography of some 50 of my
favorite guests over the last eight plus
years of doing this thing this podcast
it's a gorgeous artful compendium of the
show and copious wisdom shared there in
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table
form that provides a great taste of what
we do here at the rrp and serves as a
beautiful keepsake or gift for the
ardent fan the book is only and
exclusively available on our website
signed copies are available and we are
shipping globally direct to any coffee
table on planet earth so to learn more
and snag your copy today visit
richroll.com
vc that's richrole.com
vc
all right let's get back into it
what day was the bike rack on 59.59
yep that could have toppled the whole
thing
well here's here was a very interesting
part about that rack one it was very
violent it was it was
the hardest i've ever crashed
um i i
i believe i got knocked out um i didn't
realize it was that bad it was that bad
um and i think that's part of part of
the
i got a concussion that day for sure
um
and
what was interesting was the decision i
had to make because
i had reset my history we were at 59 and
i had done everything that i'd set out
to do and that was one of those things
like your leg snapping and a bike crash
something catastrophic where the public
goes yeah that makes sense you couldn't
continually get it and so that was one
of those moments where i like had to
really gut check
and be like oh okay
we've
you've you did what
you did enough that it's acceptable
you've made it past those personal
benchmarks that you wanted you kind of
reset history
now you have a decision making
now it's now it's a matter of doing 100
because you said you were going to do
and and keep going and the moment i
remember laying there on the ground
and i came back to really quick and they
asked me that you know i could hear that
my eyes were still closed and i could
hear them saying
you know they were on the phone calling
the ambulance
and i was like ah crap it's over
because i couldn't
you know when you crash you've got so
much adrenaline dump
and i was like okay they're calling an
ambulance maybe i can't see maybe my
legs sticking out sideways or something
then i realized it was for the other
person in the crash and they they got it
was way worse there's a woman ahead of
you something i caught in her spokes or
something yeah and she it was like she
ran into a brick wall and she went
straight over her bars and her face was
the first thing to hit aaron says i look
to the left and all i see is a bike
flying through the air and he's like oh
my gosh that bike's gonna land and just
hit and i was the person right behind
her and so she i hit her in as she was
in air because it slowed her down
stopped her but her face was literally
the first thing to hit the ground she
was definitely knocked out and needed
ambulance and medical attention
and as i was as they were saying
you know calling the medical i was like
oh crap this whole thing's over
and and i i reached up and i felt my
collarbones and i'm like oh they're not
broken right that's the first thing and
then they asked me a couple quick
questions and i answered them right away
and i'm like i'm okay
and then i was like yes i crashed and
i'm okay and we're gonna be able to
continue because that just adds to the
story right and then we made sure that
she was okay the ambulance was on her
way and most of the cyclists stayed with
her i went and talked to her
and she was like please don't wait for
me go i'm safe i'm okay and she was
super kind and uh me and three others
imagine how bad she felt yeah
me and three other cyclists
finish that bike ride um and then
continued on yeah and it was one of
those you know it was one of those
decisions or moments in the entire
journey where it's like okay this is a
pivotal decision
and
i'd be lying if i didn't say like okay i
need to weigh what public opinion is
going to be on this decision because
during the 50 we made a lot of decisions
and didn't care what public opinion was
because we were on our own journey we
were figuring out nobody had done this
before but this one i did care because i
wanted to get through this with a clean
slate as far as public opinion is
concerned and so kind of those big
decisions i made i was like okay i'm
conscious of
what the public is going to do with this
and so i was like no we're going to
continue i'm capable and that became
that became part of my decision process
every single day was like okay
am i capable of continuing or is this a
good enough excuse to quit like i'd wake
up in the morning
and and i was always amazed i'm like man
hayden is a genius like i put me
together every single night i'd wake up
and i'd be like
crap i can get in the water like i don't
have a good enough of a reason to not
start today and then i'd start biking
and i'm like no i just don't have a good
enough reason and then i'd get on the
run and i'd be walking and i'm like well
my leg hasn't broken yet and this really
sucks and i'm managing the pain but this
isn't a good enough reason and that
became
my decision process every single day is
this a good enough of a reason to quit
will the public buy off on this no okay
i've got to keep going yeah
story that bike real quick is that when
he got up and wrote offer but he's like
i guess he's good mm-hmm like he doesn't
that happened a lot faster than he
remembers that he crashed he assessed he
checked on her and he was gone and all
these cyclists were like whoa whoa
where's james he's off he's gone
so he made that decision that quickly
what day was it when you made the little
video before you got in the pool and you
were tearing up and you're like i'm just
gonna try today like you look like you
were that was
i mean i don't know if that was the
nadir of the whole thing but if there
was a breaking moment that looked like
one
it was um
and it was so interesting because i had
never gone live before that moment
i didn't go live after that like i mean
before the swim
and i just felt compelled to turn on my
phone as i'm walking from the car to the
pool i mean it's probably 200 meters
to get to there
and for some reason i turned on my phone
and i was just gonna give an update on
on how i was feeling and then i just got
completely overwhelmed by emotion
and it was this insanely impactful
moment for the viewers
and it just it it just like really
resonated with people on the journeys
that they were on they they really got
to see
okay he is he is broken he is really
struggling and he still has 20 more days
and he's not going to quit it's almost
three weeks right i mean 80 to 100
sounds close
but that's almost three weeks well that
was that was awesome
it's the craziest thing with perspective
because
i'm gonna do 20 iron man's people would
say that's insane but you're like well
you've done 80 you only have 20 like
right yeah and that became so
frustrating for me because it was like
oh you're so close you're right there
he's thinking
three weeks the public's thinking only
20 more right you know right that's not
help i mean it's coming from a good
place that's well-intentioned but it's
actually it's not really not what you
want to hear how we process and so that
was that was really the peak because you
know i was going through all the pain i
was processing everything
i know what the family's going through
at this point i know what sonny's
enduring i know we're struggling as a
couple i know all these things are
happening i know the wing man they're
falling apart
everybody's really struggling just beca
it just showcased how long of a journey
this was for that type of thing
and and again i don't know why but i
turned on my phone i was just gonna
share a few thoughts and then i had that
breakdown moment
and
that that after that moment that day's
ride became very meaningful
every single supporter that we had that
like it the cyclist that would come out
like once or twice a week they were i
didn't know this but they were all on a
big text thread together
all the different try i mean all the
different cycling clubs
unified that's so special they unified
during this time and they were on a text
thread and a text right went out
immediately anybody see
that moment anyway
there's people there they all figured
every single one of them figured out a
way to take work off that day
all of them showed up on that one day
it was super interesting because not a
word was said on the bike ride
everybody just said
it was kind of like just like a memorial
type of a ride
where they were like
we're gonna get we are here we're gonna
get you through today
you don't need to say anything
and tomorrow we'll fight again and to me
i think that was a big turning point in
us getting to the finish because for me
where i was sitting not from the outside
looking in but from my journey where i
was sitting the last 15
were
ultra flow state for me
and i was just
i knew after that breakdown and i knew
after the community had come out and
when i had 15 to go i was like
this is in the back
and i agreed that we're so close but
that's when i became super flow state
and just like every moment of every day
matters and then i
you look at my times over the last 15
days and we we yeah it was a metronome
type of state yeah
it was just execution at a high high
level
but was that so that was the inflection
point i mean what is the self-talk or
the mantra or the you know the kind of
go-to emotionally
um that you rely upon in those moments
where on that day
or
when you're up against it and you're
backed into a corner and everything
inside of you wants to quit
how do you how do you crawl out of that
headspace you shift your focus to the
community
and it becomes you're not showing up for
me i'm showing up for the other people
and by that point in the journey we'd
receive so many messages of
your journey has impacted me in this way
and then you have the conversation with
yourself
what i what i alluded to earlier we
never know who's watching
you never know who you're impacting and
so you immediately switch the
conversation to
if i don't show up today
who am i missing an opportunity to
impact
and
we'll never know but who did we impact
that didn't see or know of our story
prior to day 80 tuned into it and then
we completely changed their paradigm or
the way that they look or the way they
experience what they're doing
because we didn't
stop or quit yeah and so that becomes
the conversation of the mantra
it's it it shifts from you
or me
to
who
are we going to miss an opportunity to
impact if we don't show up today
and you quit on day 80 and you don't get
to have in my opinion the most impactful
day which is 101.
that that that doesn't even exist it's
not even in the narrative you can't set
that example you can't lead from the
front you can't bring everybody with you
to that moment
without that conversation and that
mindset of like who who am i missing the
opportunity to help today
i think
something that gets missed in this story
is the fact that
you're able to
you know execute
on this goal
by dint of the fact that you have
incrementally worked your way up and
accumulated knowledge and experience
over many years and many challenges
and
it's not a situation where
i think the instinct in people who hear
this it's just it's so unrelatable
they're like well he's a crazy
superhuman person and i don't get that
so
yeah maybe he can you know throw some
platitudes my way but like i i can't
even wrap my head around that and the
truth is very different like that
it's it's not like you're this
you your your gift really is that you're
able to suffer but you have uh you know
figured out a way to express that
through these challenges that get
incrementally more and more difficult
over the years that allow you to kind of
be in the place that you're in now i
didn't say that very uh articulately but
you know what i'm saying like this
starts on a ferris wheel for 10 days and
you know it's not like you're out
winning triathlons right away or
anything like that like you're you have
a very different path into this kind of
thing i think that is the most
most
beautiful or profound lesson that needs
to be heard today
is it is looked over that is looked over
that you're you're nobody's the expert
at the beginning of their journey
nobody is and and you have to meet
yourself where you're at today and that
be the expectation
uh
the hardest thing to do is is to start
on any journey because that's where the
highest amount of struggle is that's
where our experience and our momentum
and our success is is at its lowest
and a lot of people see the headline the
hundred and think oh
he's just born to do this kind of thing
and i said i i love saying it now that
you you can't go from zero to a hundred
and miss
all of the
the moments in between i mean our
journey started with a formal fun run
that i struggled through and sonny and i
got into sprint triathlons together and
did that for four years before even
taking on the scariest thing to us at
the time which was a half iron man i
mean it was 2004 november of 2004 was
that formal right that was a long time
ago
yes and no
like given what you've done sure it's
actually not that long ago what we've
accomplished
yeah yeah yeah it is but but but the the
important message is is that like
nobody would have said that that
individual would have gone on to set
sports endurance history
and everybody has a beginning middle and
end to their journey and we're not even
close to our hand as far as like what
are what we want to do you don't always
get to know what the journey is so like
even for us we're like well we don't
even know how this actually ends right
because we're still but it's the
audacity to start and the courage to you
know put one foot in front of the other
and i think a lot of people just get
caught up in needing to understand how
it's going to unfold and they get
paralyzed and never actually move
forward and then two
they're
that was beautifully said but
but two they're they're too and social
media this is the bad part about social
media is they're comparing themselves
against what other people are doing or
showing that they're doing
and they say i can't do that and i'm not
good enough and that's what stops them
from starting
and that that's tragic to me because
thankfully social media wasn't big where
when when we started and i didn't have
bases of comparison and people like oh
who are your mantras i mean who are your
mentors and who's this and that and who
do you look on to and i was like
i don't know i don't yeah i don't i
don't do it i don't i don't know
your grandma yeah and because yeah
there's yeah my grandmother an immigrant
that
started a business she's the ultimate
american dream that that happened in
canada
but um
but i i would not compare myself what
the current standard of excellence was
and i would go out and try to do what i
believe was possible
and here's here's the perfect example at
the time when when i said i was going to
do the 50
the baseline was kind of like the epic
five
right
and had i looked at that and said
oh the epic 5 is the standard of
excellence at the time which it was
i would have said okay i'm going to
double
that standard to do 10. so why did i go
all the way to 50
because for me personally i wasn't
comparing myself about what others were
doing accomplishing
i went out and i set the the standard of
the bar to what i thought i could do and
that's where people get into problems
and struggles is they they are now
comparing themselves
to what they see the top top guys doing
and they just get overwhelmed and they
don't start and so there's two sides of
that coin right
don't don't get sidelined by what you
see people are doing and then don't look
what other people are doing and do what
you believe is possible within yourself
so there's two kind of yeah
also you can be inspired by what other
people are taking his inspiration yes
well don't copycat it like our society
loves to copycat where james loved
triathlon and loves sports and a lot of
stuff he didn't copy anything that
anybody else did he found his own level
excellence his own creative idea on how
to be successful in the industry
it's fake it's made up he made this
thing up you know what what do you mean
you're gonna do in a full distance
triathlon in every state what about
hawaiian alaska you know it's this made
up thing so people should feel empowered
to create their own dreams and their own
aspirations based on what they see but
not copycat em yeah get creative do
something different
i remember do you remember i saw you
guys at the airport when you were
heading into hawaii met your wife yeah
yeah he's with a couple there they go
man like listen to me your wife
was so nice and i could tell she almost
pitied me
like these people i have no idea
i don't think so
this is what i felt like like
these guys are so nice and i feel so bad
they think they can do 50
it was this energy of they're cute it's
naive
because she was coming you make it sound
condescending though no no no no no no
because she was coming from the
perspective of experience having with
your children your journey and whatnot
and she was like okay that's
i mean even she was taking her lead from
me though because i was like
this guy like he's gonna do something
great like i just don't and i've said
this to you like
i think he's physically capable of doing
this but the logistics like if one thing
goes wrong like the whole thing craters
and you think you're going to go across
50 states and and like something's not
going to get like it was so kind it was
so supportive and it was almost like
this
oh you guys bless your hearts it's
amazing how much our journeys have kind
of intertwined over the past past
decades
of the airport though that was the
weirdest thing i mean that's on our way
to hawaii i know on earth i know the
exact picture i'm holding quinn he's
right that green hat sunglasses on there
like cracking down yeah and then went
out and did it and i remember coming out
like it was emotional for me like i
don't know if you remember when we did
that podcast after you finished like i
got like choked up because i was so
touched by what you guys had done and
the manner in which you carried yourself
and and the way that you
you know chose to express you know this
incredible thing and the community that
you had built and that was my first
experience getting to meet um casey and
aaron and like those guys are just i
mean they're unbelievable those guys you
know the positivity and the loyalty and
just the extent to which those guys like
show up for you is a testament to you
guys as leaders because you know you
don't get people like that unless you're
you know unless you engender that level
of kind of like trust and and love and
respect yeah they they are huge huge
parts of our journey and what's
interesting is
i have a different relationship with
those two guys and sonny has a different
relationship with those two guys and
their relationships with each other is
different it's just a very
and the way we got to meet those guys
was so random and it was just happen
chance that they were the only two guys
available that we didn't even know them
we didn't even know that that's the way
it works it is the way it works
and they have just
totally become family and well aaron did
every one of those bike rides
every single bike ride aaron was out
there dude every mile he's he's about to
go crash loaded yeah i'm gonna tell you
whole focus was james it was yeah
when i came out on day 91
um i mean it was great and all of that
but the highlight of the day was doing
the wingman wrap up and
i was like now i'm in it man i got to be
on the wingman wrap up like my day like
this is why i can't wait to guess today
yeah
um special boys uh unbelievable i
remember um
you know when uh
on
on the day 100 when i came out you were
so in the zone and like it was clear
like you you were trying to really
minimize your your
interactions with other people and just
focus on on what you were trying to
accomplish um but you did say i was like
because you were walking and i was like
are you gonna break out the run
and you're like yeah like my i think you
said at mile 20 you were gonna like let
it loose and throw it down and things
didn't actually go to plan
yeah so we had that conversation on 91
yeah yeah because and then on day 100 i
was like okay you're going to yeah he's
like i'm going to drop you said i'm
going to drop the hammer
yes as we're running because i i from on
day 100
i was oh man i was being so patient and
allowing my body to recover it was so
bad i want to run so bad we knew there
was a 101 but nobody else yeah yeah so
then he's like
well because when i'm sure we'll get to
101 pretty quick here but we we didn't
make the decision to do 101 until that
sunday the final decision so three days
before
and when i had talked to you on youtube
shirts made up and everything in 48
hours oh you did wow and they were hand
delivered uh-huh yeah it's crazy
and people think it was planned because
we had the jersey but that that was a it
was like how'd you get the jersey we're
like we don't know we don't know wow it
literally hand delivered in two days
um but when we when we had that
conversation on day 21 i mean on day 91
i was being super patient
my shin was healing i didn't have any
pain i was on the other side of the hip
i was just like
i am going to run that last day
and right from the go i started to run
and i got to i was so excited
um but i knew things started to go south
because i had i had already i mean
obviously asked so much from my body and
my mind i mean we're at the very tail
end of a quarter of a year
had done something nobody thought was
physically possible
and um i had just really nursed my body
back to health in the midst of so much
trauma and so much so much stress
and i made it all the way to 19 rich i
made it to mile 19 running and then like
you said
if things went sideways in the beginning
of the campaign they went sideways on
day 100 at day 19 and
and i i
i don't remember a lot of it because i
had to check out
and i just remember
the the wingmen were there and felicia
was there our 110 pound friend yeah
and i just remember i would i'd manage
it manage it and then my legs just i
i had i had asked everything out of them
and i they would give out on me
and it get that that collapse moments
that i had gave me
the 30 seconds to recoup and mentally we
had a mantra and it was here we go and
when you said here we go we start moving
again
and i i remember
we were on the last out and back headed
up to 8th north and we probably had 3
miles to go
it was after 19
i'd fallen apart i had lost my
my goal to run the whole thing
and i cuz i kept my legs kept giving out
on me
and we were probably mile 22 or 23 and
i lost it again and felicia caught me
and and i
right before i i went down i i was
looking at my watch and i said how fast
are we running and she's like we're
running at 9 30.
and then i and then i and then my legs
gave out and i collapsed again and then
i got back up and i said i can do better
than this
and sh her her jaw dropped
because she's like you're on day 100
of a hundred consecutive ironmans you
have given everything you got and
you've given everything you've had or
had
and your mindset right now is i can do
better than this
and that's truly where my mind was
because
you you want to go out
um
kind of with a bang like we did on the
50.
and i had been dreaming of it for
yeah a long time on that run and being
so patient along my body and i've
obviously asked a lot for my body
but that was it was kind of that moment
where
like
it was it was a proud moment for me
because i was at the end but my mind was
still there
from my perspective and um i knew i
could even in that moment i knew i could
do or be more
for people that don't know i mean you in
the final miles
you were literally collapsing you were
passing out and people had to catch you
did you ever fall all the way down to
the pavement i didn't it and i it's it's
crazy because i've i've seen pictures
now
where
it was bad and i've seen pictures now
where like casey and aaron are like
right there any any stumble or anything
that i do
they are right they're anticipating it
and
i i wouldn't have made it that last day
without them um just because of the you
know the pace that we're pushing we've
done five hours on the bike course
um which is moving yeah um and so we'd
i'd asked a lot from my body just on
that bike ride um knowing
knowing it was the last day but also
knowing
we didn't want to let on that we were
gonna do 101 yeah and i
i and i had been telling people on
social media the whole time i'm i'm
going to run a hundred yeah brace
yourself if you plan to join me that day
we're moving we're going to go sub you
know 12 11.
and um
and then you know
things fell apart but that but in the
back of my mind i said okay i can't
allude to the fact that i got to get up
and do this again tomorrow so even after
i broke myself and drove myself into the
ground
and to figure out a way to to do to do
well to do it one more time fake
celebrate yeah yeah i knew about it you
told me about it adam knew about it i
mean i remember there was like six
people yeah
um
i went down adam and i went down to the
um finish line and we were kind of
helping set up and all of that and then
adam got word from lucy i think like oh
james is really struggling he's a couple
miles out and then we jogged up to like
join the group so i was there i saw like
maybe the last mile and a half of that
and i was like oh my god like
i don't think he's like he's so close
and it just might not happen and you're
like he's going to do 101 tomorrow
i'm like forget about that like let's
just get him you know into the track you
know the high school um and then you
know running around the track like you
came back to life and you started
actually running pretty fast there at
the end right i just couldn't believe it
wasn't understood
falling down you couldn't figure out how
to put your foot on the ground without
tripping it's just so crazy the power of
the mind and when you're so close to
something and the ability
to turn it off like casey and aaron were
having a hard time keeping up on that
last lap okay because they had done this
it was also really hot
and neither of them were trained for a
full distance triathlon and aaron had
biked all of those days and so so
aaron's like i almost aaron said aaron
said one more half lap and i would have
i would have fallen over
and i just i just kept praying the
entire time i was picking up that pace
over the last two laps i was just like
don't fall in your face in front of
everybody don't
even though i've been doing it for for
six miles
prior to this but i'm like you're in the
grandstand now
just and every step i took i just i just
it was
i couldn't believe it i was i didn't
fall over i didn't fall over i didn't
pull over and i just like kept
kept just saying stay in your feet stay
in your feet was that flag that you ran
under it was really it was very cool and
then 20 minutes later you're up giving a
speech looking fresh as a daisy it's
like crazy standing for like 45 minutes
i'm like get them out of chair
well and then we did i did pictures for
two or three hours you guys were there
for a long time pretending that there
was two or three hours knowing i'm like
okay i got to get home i got to get on
the therapy table i've got one more day
30 and you had left about 15 or 20
minutes before that so
you're out there by about 8 10. the 101
just being like the core group like just
close friends
well and that was even that was even
special too because i was planning on
just just me or casey kind of doing it
uh we we didn't know
you know we had celebrated we had
celebrated and people
probably wanted their their rest too
from from the whole thing
and you know lucy went live every single
day uh on the swim and sunny did
oh yeah oh yeah sorry sunday lucy would
push you he was your partner lucy would
push the button yes um
and we wanted we wanted that moment to
where
um it was just me in the pool and that's
why we didn't tell anybody and i i
started that swim
by myself
and
the chat boards and text threads kind of
lit up exactly we wanted yeah let me
just say we wanted that we wanted that
comment dissonance of like wait a second
he's swimming is this recovery swim
what's happening
and
i imagine people thought oh he's gonna
he can't sleep and he's gonna kind of
give a breakdown of what happened right
and then before god doesn't know what to
do with himself
and then you know by the time i finished
the swim and and got out of the water
the cyclist had yeah there were 12
cyclists got together and then started
meeting us on the road and then we did
an undisclosed run location because we
wanted it to be
kind of friends and family and core the
the day 100 was so chaotic it's the
opposite of my personality it was
it was so stressful we had hundreds of
riders out there and last thing you want
to do is crash at high speeds on the
last day when you're that close and so
it was a super stressful bike ride for
me
um and then obviously the the excitement
and the emotion and the stress from that
run
and so we i wanted to kind of go out on
my terms
and the feeling on that day was so
different because we'd accomplished the
goal we did it yeah we did it and so
that like the the biggest of exhales
happened
and then it was just this fun
chatty
core group of of cyclists and runners
that we got to experience and kind of go
out on our terms and it was
it was a magical day because
you
you knew you'd finish there's no
timeline there's no expectations it's
it's the ultimate victory lap with your
closest team
and supporters from the past
however long but it also sends a very
loud and clear message that
when you've accomplished your goal and
done the thing you didn't think that you
could do
you can actually do more yeah
and it's it it just was made undeniable
i i would always get so frustrated
speaking and and someone would always
ask after the 50. could you have done
one more
and i was like they are not going to ask
me if i can do one more after this
hundred
um you know and and like like we
mentioned earlier this it was not part
of the game plan
um the week before we started to put it
into play
and uh zoca cycling clothing we we
called her up and we said hey we have
this idea
we know it's in three days any chance
and she's like send me the logo
and she was planning to her and her team
was planning to drive and be at the
finish line
and they handed that 101 jersey to lucy
at the finish line
after
and i put it on the first time that
following morning
and came out in that 101 jersey and so
that was
one of those little things that looked
like we had a plan but it came together
so fast and everyone was willing to to
to do their part to make that day happen
so you've had
some time now to reflect on all of this
perhaps get a little bit of an objective
perspective
on what it was all about
so
you know what is it like what does it
mean to you like what is it what is this
all about and has that kind of changed
or evolved i don't think we know
so james thought oh i need to take some
time off afterwards which just led him
into depression and
[Music]
you know misdirection in his life and
he's just barely now
picking back up he said you know in the
middle of august end of august is when i
kind of pick back up um
but i don't think we really know i mean
my my recovery didn't start till two
weeks ago
because it's you know i had to
care for james post and then we have
summer and all the things we have going
on and so it wasn't until the kids went
back to school that i finally like
exhaled
so i don't even think we've actually had
the time to reflect yeah because the
summer even though it was supposed to it
was very relaxing for james but not for
you know me and lucy for instance or the
other kids this is your time yeah you
get to do what you want to do now yeah
yeah i mean it's just literally catching
my breath nothing has been routine since
december for me until
you know well and here's
here's the way any project happens is
there's a preparation there's an
execution
and there's a there's a post which is in
our case it's recovery
and
that recovery still was intense for
sonny and caring for me and me going
through those struggles and and going
out of it and so this has kind of been
like this trip it kind of like okay kids
are back to school full-time kids are
in their routine and this trip has kind
of been like oh
this is a
kind of the first time where both of us
have been like
almost stress-free and relaxed and to
where we're starting to reflect and so
this this actual talk has been
kind of the start of what that
you know on the other side of that
process
i've really
actually thought about it to be honest
because even the last two weeks i've
been doing all the tasks that i've been
putting off since last december like
organizing the pantry and getting
shelves hung in the garage so
i i mean i think this is the first time
that i've really actually reflected on
it other than reflecting every day i
kept a journal every day and then did my
closet talk every day
so i had every every day i was
writing things down but
i mean like there's some ptsd that still
has to be worked through i don't you
know i don't think either of us has
really processed it yet and we don't
really know what's going to happen
because we still don't know nothing you
know we made everything wait till august
to happen
and now it's just barely august so it's
like
i don't think we really know i mean i
can't speak for james but for me
well for me my
you know sonny and i have always
been
on the same path but different
perspectives and different journey
because our roles are very different
and my role now quickly goes back into
provider and to where i'm you know
speaking full-time again and we're
planning on writing the second book and
i'm working with the film documentary
crew to produce a second documentary and
different opportunities show up in my
email every day and i get you know so
i'm back into that world of you know
business and trying to monetize what we
did and trying to help as many people as
we can and relaunch our coaching
platform i mean rewriting your
presentation yeah rewriting that whole
thing and yeah rewrite that keynote yeah
getting getting the message getting the
message
back you know in it that we want and
we we learn lessons and we evolve too on
these journeys and we want to share
those and teach those lessons too i mean
i think if someone gives the same
keynote for 20 years they're not
evolving as a person either and if you
if you listen to my keynote over the
past five or six years it's the same
story but the lessons change
and the and where i put emphasis changes
on them because i'm evolving as a person
and so what's next for me is uh very
different than kind of what's next for
sonny um outside of like our family
goals and raising our kids but
sunny is loving um doing podcasts and
getting into speaking it's actually what
she wants to do and and empowering
people and i get contacted all the time
and you you and i had conversations
recently rich where like sonny's the
unsung hero
of this journey and
people every time i speak people like uh
can we who's your wife and can we meet
her and then she's an absolutely you
have to wake up and just do one thing
every day exactly she's got to do a
thousand things and so keep her eye on
you know so many moving pieces you know
i know sonny uh
more than than most and she's she's
expressed many times so
now's not the time but now is the time
to prepare for when she gets to
tell her story and and be on stage and
do that and so she's she's got some
exciting opportunities coming up and
she's doing some some speaking and prep
work and she her her entire focus
forever has been um and still is the the
kids um and what an unbelievable
responsibility that is and the amount of
work and the attention to detail and
time that she puts into each one of our
kids um is is remarkable well your kids
are great like i love you and it's
it's a true testament to how much time
and care and love and thought that sonny
puts into it and but her time is coming
and that you know from my perspective
that's what's coming for her she's just
preparing kindling doing little things
now that'll prepare her for her true
passion and her true passion is teaching
people and speaking and talking and mine
is like disappearing to the mountains on
my bike
like i'm waiting for the
if you have a chance to see james do his
talk like i
what was that like three years ago when
you were out here and you did it like
it's very good like you're very good at
that thank you and i can't imagine how
much it's evolved since i saw it so
you know if you have an opportunity to
attend an event and to hear james share
his story it's something you should
definitely check out oh thank you i look
forward to
sonny's version
right so exciting maybe a little more
girly i don't know
but part of that talk and and what
you're all about is this subject of
mental toughness and i'm sure people say
to you all the time like how do you
develop mental toughness where does your
mental toughness come from like what is
that about how can i
be more mentally tough in my own life
the number one question yeah
and
i had to think about it a lot uh because
i didn't know how to answer because i
mean if i could write out that formula
for someone
dude my financial situation is
completely different but the reality is
is just through discussion and and
presenting and
really having the opportunity to
to be and speak in 48 different
countries and just all the different
walks of life in different cultures the
number one thing is mental toughness and
and i've just realized it's only through
taking action
it's only through like getting backed
into that corner and then having the
courage to take that next step saying
my leg might snap
but i am willing to take that next step
and you you cannot learn it by reading
it you cannot learn it by hearing
somebody those are all great like sparks
or motivation pieces to get you going on
your journey but ultimately at the end
of the day
you've got to show up you've got to
participate you have to learn and you
can't
you can't go from 0 to 100
and i couldn't have done what i did
mentally without
learning and struggling and developing
and sharpening that thing
the the the big question topic are you
born with it or can you develop it
nature versus
and in my answer
just based on my personal experiences
it's uh nurture
you have to you have to develop it you
have to work on it now we're all born
with a different baseline
jace would be a great example he
obviously has a different starting
baseline for mental toughness than some
other people do
now if he you're the kid who was on the
ferris wheel for 10 days to win a prize
right exactly your baseline baseline is
probably a little bit different like how
old are you for that
21-22 but i took that knowledge from
that experience and then i've really
showed up in my life and sharpened it
jase has an incredible opportunity to be
something very special
um in the in that mindset space and i
come across you can pick out okay
baseline's higher based on higher
baselines higher
develop that talent but we you everybody
can develop it because i'm a great
example of
this is a mental journey i'm not the
most physically gifted now you have to
the other big question is like
how much is physical and how much is
mental for what we do or the journey
that we're on
and my answer has changed over the years
um and you hear a lot of people have
different opinions it's like
seventy percent mental and
it's a hundred percent physical
and it's a hundred percent mental
cannot do what i did
if i'm very strong mentally and i'm a
300 pound man you can't mentally you
cannot drag your body through that
experience
and if you're
extremely
um
physical but have a weak mind
i've seen so many athletes that are way
more talented than i am fail because
they don't have the mental component of
it
and so you you straight up have to be a
hundred percent on both of them in order
to accomplish something like that or the
journey or push your boundaries or your
limits right it's a combination you
cannot rely solely on one or the other
and allow that to be
to get you through it you have to be so
strong at both of them or just just
doesn't work yeah
it's really
a habit or a muscle
this idea of of reflexively putting
yourself into positions where you're
going to be tested mentally emotionally
physically in all of these ways and
we're in a culture right now where it's
kind of easy to opt out of that type of
situation so you have to almost
have a little bit of extra gumption to
like seek it out and put yourself in
that situation sunny always says and she
is not lying when she says she says if i
have two paths in front of me i'm going
to intentionally pick the harder one
because i want it to hurt i want to
struggle i want to learn i want to grow
and that's exact opposite of what most
people are doing today they see two
things and go that's easy route i'm
going to take that away and that that
individual sadly it's unfulfilling yeah
it's unfeeling i think it's going to be
you know like
you you're deluded into thinking that
the happy life is the easy life but the
happy life the fulfilled life the
purpose-driven life is the life that
invites those sort of difficult
situations into your depressed and that
anxiety you know these things i'm like
i'm sure you do
because you're just taking that easy
mountain bike path it's just soft dirt
and all you do is
you know there's no challenge there's no
reason to develop any character but
they're choosing that right so it's like
well i'm sure you feel depressed like
you're accomplishing nothing hard
so
that's definitely what our culture
and our society encourages yeah what is
the easy path one of the biggest things
you learn by taking the harder path is
problem solving
and that that's what our team and sunny
has become experts at is is problem
solving that's all that's all we do
we've become master problem solvers
and we've learned how to problem solve
in the face of adversity and when you
take that path of least resistance
there's very limited opportunities or
necessity to problem solve and so you
don't learn that skill set and life is
about managing adversity and learning
how to problem solve at a high level
under
overwhelmed is probably really high oh
yeah
like
nothing's a big deal no no i'll just
figure it out let's figure it out and i
mean that was the whole journey of the
hundred was adaptation nothing was ever
the same
every day
the mood the injury the
the uh fatigue
of the crew or james the food he wanted
the people that were showing up the
weather i mean every day was adaptation
and you know i remember being late in
the journey going
man we're we're 90 days in and
nothing's ever the same
you know you grocery shop for the week
and james doesn't want anything you buy
right or you know and it's it's
literally minute to minute to minute so
you know i don't have a lot of tolerance
for people who say
you know it's just hard i don't have the
resources i can't figure it out and i'm
like did you just figure it out that's
life you just figure out nobody has the
instruction manual nobody knows what
they're doing you just figure it out and
a lot of times you don't have the time
to figure it out you have like 10
seconds to figure out a solution right
here right now
i mean and that was the premise of the
hundred was remove the chaos you know
put in normality put in consistency it's
a great illusion remove the chaos
one of those things that we thought we
were gonna be able to control and
ultimately it was exactly the same it
became just as chaotic as the 50 but for
twice as long exactly the same but
different
i mean it was just as chaotic
just as necessary to solve problems
just as dramatic
just different
it was unbelievably exactly the same
yeah as far as what's
a story that hasn't been told like a
behind the scenes like what do people
not get
or not understand about how this whole
thing unfolded
um from both perspectives james what's
yours
i think
man that's a great question i've never
been asked that before um
you're a winner because he gets asked a
lot of the same questions for a living
yeah this is my job
yeah but most people ask the same
questions you got him um
gosh
i
i i will say this few people will ever
understand what it takes
and what the four of us went through
even if you've read every book seen
every interview
um
i mean i had to put a strain on your
marriage
no no well
i may be his no no
he's like well i don't know i actually
was out there riding my bike
no um
even i didn't know one of
i i think it's sunny's actually
super mature and
one of the biggest size of relief for me
when she says i just gave you a 100-day
pass on anything you said
and anything you did and i'm like no
other woman on the planet does that but
just her level of understanding of okay
look this isn't my husband
there's a there's an imbalance there's a
there's a hormonal thing going on
there's a stress thing going on
this is totally situational and
thankfully
i did i did get a 100 day a day pass
i don't think people realize that it was
literally second to second
i mean it wasn't and i don't know if
that was everybody's experience but that
was certainly mine it was i mean
from the second i got up until
i was climbing into bed knowing i was
only getting two hours of sleep
every second was high intensity and
demanding
i mean
there was no refuge
so
that
i think about people in their own
struggles
and there's a lot of times you're like
okay i'm just gonna i'm gonna go in my
closet and take five breaths
like that didn't exist for me because i
had my family i had the crew i had james
i had i mean the film crew
james i had our working crew i had the
volunteer church stuff i was doing in
the community
my parents live in my basement
you know we have two dogs i mean there
was literally a lot of people whose
needs need to be met who are looking to
you know exactly those needs and my kids
are great for sunny to meet sonny's
which i knew was only temporary so it
was okay but 100 days is a long time
long temporary phase yep and it took me
about two years to recover from the 50
and so i promised myself this time
along the way
i would do things to prevent needing
that much time to recover
and so that's why now i'm like there's
definitely still some ptsd that i have
to process that i just haven't had the
chance to yet and i've just started that
so i definitely feel better than coming
off the 50
but um it was intense yeah every second
yeah
it's kind of like an extrapolated
version of when somebody goes into crew
like an ultra race and they've never
crewed before and they think they're
just going to be in a van listening to
music and it's going to be super cool
and cheap run by they haven't been like
wait like they're doing stuff all that
like but that's
times a thousand for a hundred days
straight yeah i think the stories that
haven't
been told yet are the stories that we
don't know yet of the people we've
impacted
i think that's that's the biggest thing
that are that are yet to come um and
those are obviously the most meaningful
stories and a lot of them we won't ever
get to hear yeah
um back on the uh mental toughness piece
you had mentioned something that's a
little bit tangential to it which is
this idea of showing up right the idea
of being consistent and how that plays
into long-term success and
the truth being that you know it's not
sexy and it's not like something that
like trends in social media it's like
that's stuff that you do every single
day no matter what that moves the needle
forward ever so slightly that puts you
in the position to be able to do
great things and achieve your dreams i i
gotta have a really cool experience i
was uh i've had the opportunity to speak
to some nfl teams and i was on the field
um for a warm up for one of the games
and one of the coaches that was there
talking to me
and he
the the quarterback was throwing the
ball to a couple different receivers
and he said watch this and he threw the
ball and the receiver caught it and
immediately tucked it
and then dropped the ball caught the
next one and immediately tucked it and
then he started throwing the ball to
a newer member of the team over rookie
and he would catch it and drop it catch
it and drop it
and he said
he's not going to make it in this league
and the reason he's a successful veteran
is because he's still
doing the small things and working on
the fundamentals that you would think
they would take for granted or not put
much attention to it but the fact that
it would catch it and still tuck it like
it was in a game situation where he was
protecting it even in a
just i'm just tossing a ball to you
right that type of thing the coaches
watch that kind of stuff and it's that
level of consistency it's that level of
showing up it's that level of
doing the small things over a long
period of time that people aren't
willing to do
that separates
that guy who makes it and that guy who
ultimately will get cut yeah
that's so true
um
how does it work with
balance i'm sure you get that question a
lot too
he does get that one yeah yeah that's
totally out of balance dude no it's not
well you're a guy with
you have four kids right yeah so you i
mean i'm sure you get that question a
lot too i do i have i have a my answer
evolves but i have kind of a
response to that but i'm interested in
yeah my answer has evolved too and now
that i have four teenage girls um
it's so fun it is fun but this is the
example that i use um
my 13 year old daughter doesn't want
to like if 25 of my time if i'm like
because people people like assume oh
family like five minutes well yeah and
people people assume okay let's say
let's break life into work play
family
and if if
balance equals 33 33 33 then you've got
to give that amount of time to each one
of those
and that's the best example is my
daughter doesn't want 33 of my time like
that that's absurd what she does want
is when i am getting over my time she
wants all of my time
and she wants me to be right there
attentive listening to the story that i
don't necessarily
all the details care about um but as
young i mean we've got one daughter who
sonny will say how was your day and
literally
from when she woke up
and when i did this and then this it's
like oh the whole time i see i would
kill for that i get a lot of like fine
yeah we have one of those too how's your
day fine
yeah
but family life and work balance doesn't
mean an equal percentage it means
whatever you're doing give
that
balance to it and
the
100 is a perfect example totally out of
balance
but that balance is that imbalance is
temporary and the sacrifices were
discussed with the family it was
committed everybody was committing to go
okay okay life's gonna be completely out
of bounds for a while and it will shift
back to imbalance and to to to break
through barriers and to reach certain
levels and why not there has to be some
nobody that navigates this life
successfully has a has a perfect balance
at all times now what you have to be
careful of is going completely out of
bounds for a really long period of time
now you're creating jeopardizing you're
jeopardizing and creating problems what
what's your thoughts on balance
i think that balance is ebb and flow you
know it's like a marriage is never 50
50. sometimes it's 60 40 sometimes it's
70 30 depending which partner needs more
attention at the time
i think life is like that you know
sometimes you don't need downtime you
need up time you know you don't need to
rest you need to be more exhilarated to
have more passion
so i think the appropriate thing with
balance is gauging
where you're at personally where your
family's at what your goals are
what the demands are and doing so
accordingly because
like you said it evolves right it
changes over time like if you're if
you're writing a book your time balance
is going to be different than when the
book's completing your marketing the
book right now your time and attention
is going to go somewhere else but it's
the same project you're trying to
accomplish the same goal but it has to
sacrifice differently to
get to the end of that or even your
activity level you're like i'm going to
be sitting a lot more in the day yeah
than if i'm working in my garden yeah i
mean it's it's a tricky thing i mean i
think we're
you know i think i think culture
dictates this idea that um we should be
aspiring to live our life in this super
balanced way every single day and that
our time and attention is equally
apportioned you know throughout the
hours of the day so that everybody's
taken care of and you're taking care of
yourself and it sets people up for
failure and for guilt like we beat
ourselves up because we're not adhering
to that kind of norm and that norm is an
illusion like i don't think anybody
adheres to that norm successfully and on
top of that if you want to do something
amazing your life is going to have to
look unlike other people's lives i mean
that's just the truth like
nobody achieves something great with
some perfectly balanced life like you
have to be temporarily out of balance so
that something gets an extraordinary
amount of time attention
period right you're peaking i think of
it as a pendulum and that pendulum has
to swing back like you have to make sure
that the important buckets in your life
are are being attended to so that you're
you don't capsize completely
but
you have to be in a situation where you
can kind of vacillate in and out of
these things and that's okay as long as
it always kind of like tips back in the
right direction yeah beautifully and
don't you think that people know when
their life is out of balance sure
because either you're sad
or you're too tired or you're this or
that
and then you assess right well our
bodies are amazing too they give us
signals yeah i mean i think yeah and i
think it's it's more i like to think of
it more in terms of attention like where
are you placing your attention and is
that the right place to be placing your
attention and when you're placing your
attention on that thing are you giving
it
all that you have
and you can pull out of it and then re
you know
rejigger and focus it somewhere else but
being present for what you're doing and
i think you know big piece of like the
lesson that i extract one of the lessons
i extract from the hundred
is this mindfulness piece like this idea
of being totally present with what
you're doing like you can't it's too
overwhelming right the only way
that you got through it is by being
exactly where you your feet were you
know every second of every mile of every
day yeah as soon as i looked too far
ahead it was catastrophic
well and you couldn't have balance he
had one job yeah swim
bike and run that was it
if he tried to implement anything else
like you said
he couldn't have accomplished it it
couldn't have happened right so yeah
that was out of balance but the
appropriate thing to do is to
immediately
you know balance out your time efforts
and energies as soon as that project is
done and i think that's where people
struggle i think they try to continue
what they're doing you know they don't
recover after a race they just continue
their training right but i think you
articulated that beautifully yeah and
here sorry here's a great example of i
sacrificed a lot of family time
during those hundred years hundreds of
years
get that get the mri
immediately
100 days but what did that sacrifice
like at what level did that sacrifice
now bless my family more family time and
create more family time because of that
sacrifice and so
imbalance for a
quarter of a year or for a time period
but that sacrifice in turn will create
an opportunity for me to leverage
a leverage point yeah yeah well here's
one for you and i'm wondering whether
you relate to this
myself being someone who who who like
appreciates suffering and i feel like i
have a capacity for that as well
what happens with me is
i equate
maybe not success but whether i've given
my all to something is calibrated and
locked up with how much i've suffered so
whether it's a book or writing a speech
or preparing for a pi whatever it is
it's like if i haven't suffered like i
didn't work hard enough on it like i
could work harder on it like i could i
could really go down the rabbit hole on
this you know i have to really like feel
it you know in order to feel like i did
a good job
and
things outside of endurance sports don't
necessarily work that way right so the
challenge that like one of the things
i'm trying to learn right now
is can i hold these things a little bit
more lightly and and and be more in the
allowing rather than in the in the kind
of self-will forcing of it because
that's my instinct right and that
instinct doesn't always drive the best
result
in areas that are outside of like
endurance sports yeah i battle with that
too like if it
you know
back to taking the path of you know
least resistance or the hard road
sometimes when you accomplish something
if it wasn't harder what is the did
you get i could have been i could have
done better or that that project's not
what it should have been i but sometimes
it just is easy and it's okay and that's
i think that's what you're saying you're
trying to learn is like it's okay to not
have to suffer through something that
still be an excellent piece of product
it's better if you get out of the way
and just allow it to be allow it to
express itself in a more kind of like
organic natural way everything to try to
force it yeah everything doesn't have to
be hard or strong
it doesn't it doesn't have to be that's
the thing right
i think people hear some of the times
when when we say that as like oh okay i
i have to struggle it has to be hard i
have to face adversity in order to learn
no
that's just where learning is at its
peak
but you can still do things and
accomplish things and it'd be easy and
it's a breeze and it's fun and it's
enjoyable and it's enjoyable
um and so yeah there's there's obviously
definitely two sides two sides of that
coin and i'm i'm learning i have to
learn that as well so it's kind of a
hard lesson because it just cuts across
like my instincts yeah we're cut from
that same wall that same old are any of
your kids into this stuff like our
suffering or no just just like the
multi-sport thing or are they just on
their own trip they're they're on their
own trip and and
that's that's one of the things that i
one of the biggest goals i set out as a
parent was i am not going to force my
passions my dreams on my kids i'm gonna
allow them to be on their own journey
and i'm gonna
help create opportunities for them
but ultimately i want them to follow
their passions
and um
i would say quinn
and as of the last six months no i'd say
quinn and and daisy um have the have a
great baseline for suffering but quinn
only as of the last six months right
he's just wanted to be a little kid but
he's showing a youtube channel now
though oh yeah
so this is
in in conjunction with james is saying
quinn has found this passion
and he is continuing to grow in this
passion so he is continuing to learn new
sports he's moving to parkour on the
ground and he's doing some ninja warrior
stuff but here's what else is cool he's
filming it he's editing it
he's posting he enjoys that part of it
and it's so cool to see so for his
birthday we got him a tripod because he
has friends he gets to hold his camera
for him and
it's been really neat to see him not
only
do what the sport he loves but to
continue to learn and grow
in different you know parts of the sport
so it's been really neat to see him
grow into that because before he's like
i just want to wear spiderman costumes
and dress up right where now he's
finally showing some passion for
athletics and he's played lacrosse for
years but it was because his cousin
played and so we wanted to hang out his
cousin
but now he's starting to show a little
bit and then our daughter daisy
that james mentioned she's our third
daughter she just turned 15.
she is the most easy going
she's just like james she's like i don't
care if it's messy i don't care if it's
clean i don't care if my homework is
good grades bad grades i don't care but
the second she sets her mind to
something she is unstoppable and it is a
force to be reckoned with
the trick is finding the right thing
so she
you know
goes through life doing things her way
and then every once in a while she finds
something and she just dives into it
so that's really cool because that's a
lot how james is james is so easy going
he's just go with the flow
he has a play mentality and he's just
like yellow personality procrastinator
at heart
like he really is but then when he finds
that thing and he turns it on he turns
it on
i mean lucy lucy's just like
hardcore all the time lily she just
wants to play and have fun and then she
realizes being organized it's better for
her
and then dolly or other daughters just
like i just wanted to hear makeup yeah
so it's interesting how it's all
different but those two are the ones
that show
kind of the turn on where it's like from
normal
yeah that's switch thing i mean that is
you were talking about nurture versus
nature perhaps that's a nature thing i
mean you are a god like when i think of
you it's like yeah your word is your
bond you say you're going to do this
thing like i know james is going to
fulfill on that promise or die trying
like whatever's going to happen like
he's he you care so much about this
promise that you make whether it's to
yourself or to the public
and that becomes like this anchor
that holds your you accountable to
yourself in terms of like accomplishing
these goals
yeah and and it's fun it is fun to watch
those kids that
that follow in that and you can start to
see but as far as doing what we do and
none of them have any interest zero
um we keep trying to pitch like mountain
biking
but you did like a big family hike up
this mountain the other day they do that
they love that it's family time dolly
was
crazy excited the whole time i just love
hiking this is so much fun and she's the
kind of girl that like we have to get
her out there and then she realized
sonny's this way too it's like
i have to get sunny to go do an activity
she's very resistant and then she does
it and it's like this is the best time
i've ever had a minded person i've ever
had in my life
right and so no we do stuff as a family
they they're they're very active and
very healthy and they love to get out
and do family stuff like that it's not
something like triathlon yeah maybe golf
independent sport i don't know we'll see
yeah we'll see
well there is no such thing as an
individual sport as individual as you
know triathlon and and multi-sport is i
mean this really was a beautiful team
effort and family journey that you guys
went on it's super inspiring to so many
people
um
i love you guys a ton i appreciate you
coming to share today and maybe we can
just end this with
a few thoughts
for the person out there
who does struggle with getting off the
couch or just figuring out how to
you know bring that will into into
execution
you know how do you start to show up
like what if you've never showed up or
you you haven't flexed that muscle
before and you're inspired by you know
what you guys have have done and the
example that you've set like how do you
get that person activated yeah i think
the biggest thing is is helping them
realize that we started from the very
beginning
um same same self-doubt same
outside criticism coming in same trying
to battle that conversation
um and and just set yourself the
smallest goals one of the best examples
i've ever read was from the book atomic
habits james clear when he said okay
you don't go to the gym you're 350
pounds
your goal is to go to the gym for
literally five minutes
when five minutes is up you have to
leave the gym
and the person on the beginning of their
journey would be like i'm not going to
accomplish anything by going to the gym
for five minutes a day
because the flip side of that is someone
says okay
i'm gonna go to the gym 90 minutes six
days a week and they fail every single
time it's inevitable
it always happens nobody that is at the
beginning of the journey can set an
expert level goal and accomplish it
and the whole the whole process or
reason for doing that is because it's
it's it's a mind it's a mind deal and
you now become even though you've only
gone to the gym for five minutes
if over the past two weeks you've gone
to the gym every day for five minutes
you now can say the words i'm a gym goer
right i'm the kind of person who goes i
go to the gym i go to the gym every
single day and so my advice to someone
who's just starting is one absolutely
realize that your journey is worth it
you're worth showing up on your own
journey and meet yourself where you're
at today
and set that expectation but then set
yourself such almost a ridiculously
achievable goal so that you can start to
gain confidence and momentum
and once you do that now push the limits
now start to go you can't go from zero
to 100. my journey didn't start
off the couch 100 ironmans it started a
formal fun run that i struggled through
that sunny made fun of me for that put
us on this journey so ultimately it's
her fault that we're here yeah yeah um
but really that's my big that's i take
care of created this whole insanity this
monster so that's my advice is meet
yourself where you're at today
um believe in yourself know that you're
enough and to to just start and set
yourself almost a ridiculously low goal
to give yourself some confidence and
momentum
i'd say find something hard to do every
day
for some people that heart is
you know brushing your teeth brushing
your teeth or
talking to the person
checking you out at the grocery store or
to just leave the house or to
you know make a phone call that you
have been putting off but i mean every
time i mountain bike if i'm on an easy
stretch i intentionally look for like
hard rocks and stuff to hit because i'm
like there's no better time to practice
going over those rocks than in this safe
zone
so find
hard things to do inside your safe phone
safe zone and just do it one one hard
thing a day yeah one hard thing
solid advice both you guys
i'm gonna resist the temptation to ask
you the question that i'm sure everybody
asks you at the end of these things
what's next i'm not going to ask you
that i don't want to know what's next
there doesn't have to be an uh next i've
got a great answer you guys are do you
all right i didn't ask you by the way i
know you don't i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna volunteer let me handle this hey
so what's next what's next yes um
so obviously we're in the recovery phase
of what we're doing um that is what's
right in front of us what's next but
i've kind of gone down this rabbit hole
of recovery of of biohacking
the mind and the body and all of the
incredible tools that are out there if
you have access to them to utilize them
just with food and just everything
what's next for me would be to live a a
healthy sustainable
quality of life beyond age 105. so he
keeps changing it there you go it used
to be 100. i know but then you said you
said you're going to live i said i can
let i'm going to live as a widow because
i'll make it to 100 but you'll be 105. i
know so i said 100 because it's five
years difference see i had to adjust it
because i want to be with you i got a
couple of guys you should talk to and a
couple books for you to read i'm reading
dave ashford's book right now yeah
you read david sinclair's book
i should read that surrogate this guy
started young it was just on the podcast
has a book that just came out called
growing young cool i'm i'm fascinated
with all of it because obviously i've my
whole career has been breaking my body
down
and i'm going to the point now i'm like
okay i need to accidentally stress i
need to build this back up so that i can
hit this goal of what's next and living
to beyond 105. so well the amazing thing
is throughout this whole thing you
really didn't lose any body weight like
you maintained your your weight in both
campaigns
yeah people ask us all the time is he on
steroids or something no he's just born
like that no i just eat a lot of food
yeah
i ate so much food it was one of the
hardest things we did was eat that
amount of food to maintain it yeah it's
been crazy um you guys are welcome back
here anytime i love talking to you today
we love you and uh
so people should
um check out your book redefine
impossible there's the the documentary
the iron cowboy the 50 50 50 journey or
something what is it called it's called
iron cowboy currently sits on amazon
prime right cool and then uh to follow
our anything crazy we do or what is next
is we post everything on instagram so
iron cowboy james and then everything
can be linked or found through our
website ironcowboy.com cool right on
sunny
any final words sonny joe lawrence on
instagram i'm not very good at posting
but i've set this new goal because
people keep asking me to post people
keep requesting and i just i have to get
in the habit you have to get out of your
comfort zone
i did those closet talks to day 98 and
then all of a sudden instagram wouldn't
let me load videos
so i haven't been able to load any
videos i can't
with it it's this weird thing i've tried
deleting that but everything so that i
got out of the habit
and so i've been getting requests like
please post more so i'm i'm doing it
starting the habit it's happening you
are a problem solver that sounds like a
problem that you could probably solve
almost sounded like an excuse this is
bad
we should end this right now no
explanation but this is it this is the
new habit
i'm gonna i'm gonna log on to instagram
tomorrow and see what's what's gonna
happen
tomorrow okay good for good i know i got
a deadline to do something today peace
all right you guys thank you
[Music]
you